[Musique]
bonjour mesdames messieurs ici céline
galipeau bienvenue à cette émission
spéciale il est actuellement 10 heures à
londres et dans une heure les
funérailles d'état de la reine elizabeth
2 seront célébrées à l'abbaye de
westminster c'est un des édifices
religieux les plus célèbres de londres
vous l'avez peut-être déjà visité très
important pour les britanniques mais
aussi pour elle personnellement puisque
c'est là notamment que la reine s'est
mariée avec le prince philippe c'était
en 1947 c'est là aussi qu'elle a été
couronnée en 1953 ce sera l'occasion
pour le monde de lui rendre hommage un
peu plus de 2000 invités ont déjà
commencé à prendre place dans plusieurs
centaines de chefs d'état une trentaine
de têtes couronnées de nombreux
dignitaires on promet un hommage à la
hauteur de la souveraine et de son règne
certains parlent des funérailles du
siècle qui seront aussi regardée par des
millions de téléspectateurs à travers la
planète certains 10,4 milliards de
téléspectateurs du jamais vu c'est donc
le début d'une longue journée d'adieux
d'abord à londres puis à windsor où il y
aura une autre cérémonie ensuite en fin
de journée le cercueil de la reine sera
déposée dans la crypte royale de la
chapelle saint georges aux côtés de son
mari le prince philip
alors tout de suite je vous présente les
invités qui vont nous accompagner tout
au long de ces cérémonies pendant les
prochaines heures estelle bouthillier
analyse de la monarchie bonjour estelle
marc laurendeau journaliste spécialiste
de la monarchie également bonjour marc
et révérend bertrand olivier doyenne
montréal recteur de la cathédrale
anglicane correction de montréal bonjour
moi je n'ai pas vu ravi de vous avoir
ici à 7h vraiment on l'apprécient
beaucoup alors marche je vais commencer
avec vous parce que on s'attend à un
événement d'un an plus d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle c'est même difficile de
mesurer tout ce qui va se passer c'est
du jamais vu et votre préambule de
l'essai bien entendre tel événement
historique auquel nous allons assister
aux funérailles d'état vous le disiez
où peu de gens ont du sens c'est à dire
que les rois par essence mais des grands
personnages de l'histoire britannique
comme sir isaac newton ce qui va faire
plaisir aux scientifiques c'est winston
churchill également eu des funérailles
d'état et c'est pas tout le monde parmi
les grands personnages et puis on en a
pas eu depuis justement celle de
churchill il faut les distinguer des des
funérailles de cérémonies des
funérailles comme par exemple diana pu
avoir des funérailles avec un certain
protocole mais là c'est funérailles
d'état dans un lieu historique et
fléchés là que guillaume le conquérant a
été couronnée alors
très long c'est fabuleux parce que ce
que nous allons vivre aujourd'hui est ce
qu'ils vont nous avons le retenir c'est
pour ça que beaucoup de gens voulaient
être la douleur 1 pour vivre ce moment
estelle oui en effet c'est ses
funérailles d'état qui ont lieu à 8 mai
à l'habiller de west mais il n'y a pas
eu de funérailles d'état depuis georges
2760 alors évidemment c'est aussi
important parce que les autres
funérailles des monarques ont plutôt eu
lieu à windsor melox aswey semaine se
chargent et déchargent et l'histoire et
en plus l'or pour la reine elizabeth
aussi si c'est un lieu pour l offre
vraiment exceptionnel alors c'est elle
qui avait souhaité d'ailleurs que vous
aillez lieu à wes munitions oui
exactement donc il ya beaucoup de deux
d'éléments dans ces funérailles que l
avait déjà déterminés ce qu'elle
aimerait avoir et je suis convaincu que
le duc de norfolk organiser les
funérailles le premier perd d'angleterre
ont suivi la beaucoup de ses
instructions alors elle ne voulait pas
de cérémonie ennuyeux c'est ce qu'on dis
donc qu'est à quel genre de cérémonie
doit-on s'attendre est quand même une
année assez traditionnel dans le rite
anglican en utilisant les textes du
bouquet comme entre le livre de la
prière commune de 562 qui date encore de
l'époque de kramer donc au niveau au
moment de la réformation
c'est aussi un essai d'un événement
rassembleur au niveau religieux on voit
que beaucoup d'invités communiqué et
d'autres traditions de deux fois sont
invités aussi l'église d'angleterre est
l'église établi mais qui je regarde aux
intérêts de toutes les personnes deux
fois en bretagne et donc il ya une
valeur symbolique aussi de rassembler
toutes les personnes de foi au pays donc
le meilleur de la musique on va avoir
certainement la musique les chants corot
a qui vont ponctuer ce service les
anglicans aime bien chanter aime bien
que la musique c'est ce et puis des
textes des textes traditionnels donc
beaucoup de gens vont reconnaître si on
peut dire parce qu'ils ont été élevés
avec ça reste donc un truc très courant
en tout cas pour les personnes qui sont
dans les universités que c'était un clip
qui nous la chapelle on utilise encore
ces rites anciens qui parle un peu d'un
autre monde à notre âge mais en même
temps qui
est vraiment la réforme on était partis
l'année gouvernement de réforme c'était
traduire traduire la liturgie dans la
langue que je pouvais comprendre mais
c'est maintenant rester ce cette façon
dans les rh expire ça reste ça reste un
petit peu mystérieux pour l'étape pour
les pour la génération maintenant donc
ça donne
air différent ce sera très solennelle
cette cérémonie on peut imaginer coûté
des grands personnages seront leurs
l'archevêque de canterbury ya des gens
qui vont prononcer des sermons qui ont
été des invités sont des gens de la
famille royale pour les premiers
oui dans ce lieu il ya à peu près 30
monarque déjà qu'ils ont été enterrés
les grands personnages historiques de
l'angleterre sont là je le mentionnais
le jour même où il a sa statue dans
cette tâche dans cette cathédrale inouïe
alors c'est chargé d'histoire et
solennelle oui la vie de wesminster ci
est il à rennes voulait ça pour ça
d'ailleurs pas c'est un lieu très public
1 c'est-à-dire windsor est un peu plus
en retrait alors si elle voit que c'est
là qu'elle doit être non pas inhumé en
tout cas où elle va avoir sa sépulture
définitive tandis que elle voulait que
la cérémonie se déroule là-bas parce que
c'est au milieu de tous là près du mort
près des grands et grandes institutions
alors très
célèbre de londres oui le plus
accessible et plus célèbres vous pouvez
pas aller à londres une poésie stella by
alors tout le monde l'a vu un moment où
l'autre ne serait ce que pour les
funérailles de diana
différents événements et tenter de la
famille qui ont été célébrés là mais
encore une fois les funérailles d'état
rarissime dans cette dans cet endroit
est pour ça que c'est un lieu c'est un
moment inouï que nous allons vivre et
des centaines de milliers de
britanniques se sont massés déjà sur les
routes certains ont dormi sur place pour
être présents il y aura aussi certaines
certaines personnes qui ont été invitées
par exemple les travailleurs de la santé
qui ont travaillé qui ont oeuvré pendant
la pandémie qui ont été invités en plus
de tous les dignitaires de la famille
royale on a besoin de justement de de
souligner le travail de ces gens là
parce que ils ont déployé des services
temps incroyable pendant les dernières
années et on disait que les policiers de
londres s'attendre à voir plus de deux
millions de personnes le long du
parcours et qui est à certains endroits
l'eau il va avoir vu deux personnes de
deux feront donc ça ça va être vraiment
le pour le service de sécurité c'est
quelque chose qu'ils n'ont
jamais vu encore même ça dépasse les
événements qu'il ya eu autour des
olympiques en 2012 donc
voici les images de ces dignitaires donc
qui s'installe qui prennent place dans
l'abbaye de westminster les portes sont
ouvertes à trois heures précise ce matin
donc de plus de 2000 personnes en fait
de 1200 personnes seront présentes pour
assister à cette cérémonie on voyait
tout à l'heure on apercevait le
président américain joe biden justin
trudeau est également sur place
son épouse pendant qu'on voit
c'est
désordre l'ordre de saint-jean on a vu
précédemment des membres de l'ordre de
la jarretière alors c'est vraiment là
les grandes unitaire de l'état qui
commencent à arriver très bien alors
plusieurs de nos envoyés spéciaux sont
bien sûr sur place ils seront nos yeux
ils nous auraient et allons tout au long
de la journée je commence avec un zèle
vod gorgui ce que je retrouve au pont de
waterloo avec une vue imprenable sur la
capitale sur le quartier de westminster
bonjour hazeb
bonjour céline alors aidez-nous un peu à
capter l'atmosphère à londres je disais
des centaines de milliers de personnes
se sont massées le long du parcours on
parle même d'un million de personnes
pour faire leurs adieux à la reine
racontez nous ce qui est en train de se
passer autour de vous
ben voilà on peut voir beaucoup
d'anglais qui arrivent d'un peu des
quatre coins de l'angleterre si vous
voulez on les a vus arriver ces quelques
jours il y en a qui ont campé devant
l'abbaye de westminster et je vous
dirais qu'aujourd'hui fait un temps
assez gris qui reflète un peu la
tristesse la nostalgie des britanniques
ils disent au revoir à leurs rêves alors
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
l'aboutissement de dix journées de deuil
pendant dix jours les britanniques ont
pu se recueillir pendant quatre jours et
se sont recueillis à la chapelle ardente
est justement le dernier couple parce
que ça permet à 6h30 ce matin le dernier
couple qui s'est recueilli sur le
cercueil la femme a dit qu'elle était
très heureuse que c'était une journée
historique pour elle que c'était même
plus un pratiquement aussi important que
le jour de la naissance de ces enfants
c'est pour vous montrer à quel point les
britanniques les anglais tenait vraiment
à cette race et rennes donc ça va être
une journée vraiment historique les gens
s'attendent à bon comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure il va y avoir des chefs
d'état des rois des princes mais aussi
des gens de la communauté anglaise des
gens du n est celle d'une nation rêve se
baisse des infirmières des médecins et
vous savez ces funérailles ont été
méticuleusement préparé aussi par la
reine on sait que l'art la reine a le
souci du détail depuis tout petit là
vous entendez la sirène savez il ya
beaucoup de policiers également dix
mille policiers en tout donc londres est
vraiment en état d' alerte alors on
risque d'entendre beaucoup les sirènes
de policiers alors je vous disais que la
reine a vraiment préparer ses
funérailles d'état comme vous l'avez dit
elle ne voulait pas quelque chose
d'ennuyeux c'est ce que l'archevêque de
york a dit et donc elle avait le souci
du détail elle voulait vraiment que
toutes les communautés soit représentée
et c'est ce qui va arriver un peu plus
tard donc en fait le cercueil va quitter
west au rôle à 10h44 précisément pour
aller vers le choeur de l'abbaye et sera
suivie d'une procession des membres de
la famille royale et la sq ont appris
cette nuit c'est que les arrières petits
enfants de la reine vont suivre cette
procession donc derrière le roi charles
la reine consort camilla le prince le
prince william et sa femme kate y aura
les enfants du prince william le prince
george et la princesse charlotte qui ont
9 et 7 ans donc son tout petit ils vont
suivre cette procession pour accompagner
le cercueil vers le choeur de l'abbaye
évidemment tous les britanniques seront
rivés à leur écran il ya des écrans
géants un peu partout dans les parcs
royaux on a parlé à des gens tout à
l'heure qui nous disaient oui à 11
heures pile londres sera complètement
silencieux si vous voulez tout le monde
va être rivés aux écrans et va
évidemment suivre cette finira d'état
qui sont vraiment historique là depuis
winston churchill et 1965 alors par les
noisettes de la sécurité parce qu'on le
disait il ya quand même énormément de
chefs d'états de dignitaires qui sont
sur place beaucoup de britanniques aussi
vous le disais donc c'est aussi un
dispositif de sécurité exceptionnel
exceptionnel et puis surtout c'est la
réputation de ce coach omnium qui est en
jeu là avec tous ces chefs d'état le
président macron le président biden tous
ces princes des émirats arabes le sultan
de brunei l'empereur du japon donc pour
les britanniques le chef pas le seul
celui qui dirige camden yards ai dit
qu'en fait ça fait des années qu'ils
organisent tout ça c'est fait des années
qu'ils se préparent ils savaient que les
funérailles d'état la reine celle être
quelque chose de gros et que pour ce qui
est de la sécurité ça allait être un
cauchemar un casse tête parce qu'il faut
qu'ils aient sur la sécurité non
seulement de leur propre chef d'état
mais également des personnalités
étrangères il ya donc on parle de dix
mille policiers on parle de 2000
militaires également et puis aussi des
policiers qui vont être en civil qui
vont se mêler à la foule pour s'assurer
vraiment qu'il n'y ait pas d'attentats
terroristes s'est évidemment le pire
scénario mais ils sont vraiment préparé
à tout mais ils sont quand même très
discret on sent pas trop l'attention
dans les rues voyez ici le pot est quand
même ouvert il ya encore des magasins
ouverts à londres donc on sent que les
villes quand même continue à fonctionner
normalement mais a quand même une
présence policière
extrêmes là et on a vu au cours des
derniers jours quand même une atmosphère
très bon enfant les gens étaient assez
heureux de se rassembler en attendant de
pouvoir aller se recueillir
devant le cercueil de la reine mais
aujourd'hui est-ce que l'atmosphère a
changé est ce que c'est plus lourd est
ce que c'est plus sombre un peu parce
que ce sont les adieux c'est la dernière
fois qu'ils vont pouvoir rendre hommage
à cette reine
mais je vous dirais que c'est que pc
plus nombreux les gens sont plus tristes
et réalise qu'en fait ils ne verront
plus la reine que c'est son dernier
voyage vers windsor plus tard dans la
journée et qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
les adieux à la reine qui les a gouverné
pendant 70 s qui a été assez incroyable
ces lignes pendant ces derniers jours
c'est de voir à quel point le peuple
c'est une il a derrière la reine y avait
plus de divisions politiques on sent
vraiment que la reine elle incarnait un
peu cette stabilité cette constance et
que tous se retrouvaient un peu en elle
savait elle était présente durant la
seconde guerre mondiale elle était
ambulancière mécanicienne la famille
royale n'a pas quitté le palais de
buckingham pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et les plus âgés des
britanniques s'en souviennent donc ils
disent que la reine a toujours été là
jusqu'à la pandémie de 2020 c'est elle
vraiment qu'il les a rassemblés qui les
a rassurés donc de voir qu'elle ne sera
plus là le prince charleroi charles
plutôt à 73 ans et ne veut pas renier
aussi longtemps qu'elle évidemment donc
il ya quand même une tristesse et les
gens sont quand même heureux aussi
d'avoir été vivant entre guillemets
pendant le règne d'elizabeth ii parce
que c'est une reine je pense qu'il va
qui va pas être oubliée de sitôt oui une
reine qui a marqué l'histoire pendant
qu'en voix deux images de emmanuel
macron et d'autres dignitaires merci
beaucoup à z on vous retrouvera un petit
tard
et on va tout de suite rejoindre
madeleine qui elle se retrouve qui se
trouve sur le toit de la maison du
canada 7 à trafalgar square bien sûr le
canada qui a une importante délégation
madeleine pour les funérailles commencer
par le premier ministre
oui le premier ministre qui connaît la
reine depuis qu'il est tout petit la
reine a connu douze premiers ministres
canadiens il y en a cinq céline qui sont
ici qui font partie de la délégation
canadienne une des plus importantes au
monde il ya donc justin trudeau
évidemment paul martin stephen harper
kim campbell jean chrétien aussi qu'il
avait des liens très étroits avec la
reine était d'ailleurs un des seuls
répressif viande air de l'ordre du
mérite décerné par la reine un des seuls
au canada donc vous voyez il y avait cet
attachement entre la reine et le canada
elle a visité le canada plus que tout
autre pays au monde 22 fois qu'elle est
venue au canada et je vous dirais que
les canadiens le lui rendaient bien il
était attaché à la reine à peu près les
deux tiers des canadiens disaient qu'ils
avaient un sentiment favorable à
l'endroit de la reine qu'ils avaient une
impression favorable d'elle et ça c'est
beaucoup plus que le capital de
sympathie auquel a droit son fils le roi
charles donc on peut se demander dans le
contexte actuel est ce que cette
transition la pourrait on est un des
boss sont l'avenir de la monarchie au
canada vous allez voir que le premier
ministre justin trudeau a pas
l'intention du tout de l'initier ce
débat là je me suis entretenu avec lui
hier
on en a vécu des débats constitutionnels
changer notre système de gouvernement
n'importe quel moment si difficile
maintenant on est dans une ère où il ya
des grandes transformations que ce soit
le virage vert que ce soit à la réalité
d'un le monde politique internationale
qui a changé profondément avec
l'invasion de la russie de l'ukraine on
est dans tellement un moment complexe et
compliqué que de faire un changement
aussi profonde dans un système qui est
parmi les meilleurs systèmes les plus
stables dans le monde maintenant pour
moi c'est pas une bonne idée
donc madeleine visiblement pas de
changement en vue mais quand même les
sondages sont assez claires les
canadiens sont de moins en moins
attachés à la monarchie
les vins sondage léger qui a été publié
ces derniers jours céline qui disait que
les trois quarts des canadiens ne sont
pas attachés à la monarchie au québec
c'est encore plus donc on sent que ça va
être peut-être difficile d'éviter le
débat et le bloc québécois qui veut
couper les liens avec la monarchie le
npd qui est pas contre l'idée d'un débat
mais j'entendais le premier ministre
justin trudeau dire en entrevue à la bbc
ce matin il disait selon lui que les
liens monarchique allait être maintenue
tout au long de la prochaine génération
celle de ses enfants je voudrais c'est
une prédiction a plutôt long terme mais
moi je peux vous en faire une peut-être
un plus court terme avec la composition
actuelle de la chambre des communes ce
serait illusoire de penser que le canada
veut couper ses liens avec la monarchie
parce que la formule constitutionnel
pratiquement barré à double tour les
liens monarchique avec le canada
faudrait pour l'abolir avoir l'appui de
la chambre des communes du sénat des
assemblées législatives de toutes les
provinces canadiennes
alors ça avec seulement la chambre des
communes actuelles avec le parti libéral
qui est contre avec le parti
conservateur aussi qui tient à celje
monarchique on peut pas voir qu'à court
terme on coupe les liens avec la
monarchie mais ce serait ouvrir une
boîte de pandore et personne n'est prêt
à le faire pour l'instant merci beaucoup
madeleine à plus tard
au revoir
oui alors je retrouve mes invités parce
que évidemment dans d'autres pays on a
amorcé cette réflexion on peut penser à
l'australie à la nouvelle-zélande
mahmad qui a déjà quitté qui a déjà
laissé aller la main ici le canada ne
semble pas prêt à ce moment ci à
27,10 promise est tout à fait et ils
vont justement madeleine blé morin
effectivement la constitution est
totalement verrouillée mais il ya cette
porte de sortie qui évoquait des
chroniqueurs ces jours ci la possibilité
d'un référendum c'est à dire qu'on
consulte ray tous les canadiennes puis
si on en juge d'après les sondages pour
ce léger léger il ya un gain solide ou
six qui est un sondage important et qui
montre les mêmes tendances on pourrait
constater constaté une volonté et
certaines provinces pourraient prendre
l'initiative y en a même qui est de
façon très audacieuse disait en
constatant ce résultat on pourrait
porter sa la cour suprême et vous vous
souvenez du jugement sur la sécession
s'il ya une majorité assez consistante
ça oblige le canada à négocier avec le
québec et de la même manière on serait
obligé même si sur laquelle les deux
premiers deux chefs de partis actuels
tard monsieur trudeau que monsieur
poilievre ne serait pas du genre à
remanier la constitution
mais si une pression forte qui se
manifestent vingt deux ou deux provinces
le débat peut reprendre parce que
j'écoutais oui si ce qu'on disait sur le
sur la continuation que va donner le
règne de charles ix a un côté
imprévisible que sa mère n'avait pas eu
lieu il ya tout un facteur toute une
série de facteurs devraient viser haut
pour en parler
que j'arrivais de charles comme roy
allait précipiter un peu cette réflexion
et de discussion peut-être pas encore au
canada mais dans d'autres pays c'est le
cas oui c'est certain mais il reste ça
va être des discussions on va débattre
de la situation mais il ya un pas à
faire discuter et agir mais quand même
l'idée va être lancé et puis mais c'est
certain que dans un certain nombre de
pays ont le débat va être lancée parce
que comme vous disiez le roi charles n'a
pas le même
la même stature que la reine avait à ce
sujet le lem popularité commencé cet ami
de l'élan car depuis le décès de la
reine elizabeth la popularité du roi
charles aux remontées mais là je crois
que c'est plus
par la situation actuelle on va lui
donner sa chance pour quelques mois
quelques peut-être la première année
jusqu'au couronnement mais après ça va
falloir qu'ils qui vraiment montre ses
couleurs et c'est là où les mêmes points
beaucoup moins populaire que son fils ou
même que j'épouse son fils canoë ça
c'est certain ça c'est certain alors
revenons à cette cérémonie et peut-être
parler du du lieu où ça se passe parce
que c'est quand même
un endroit assez sacré là pour la
monarchie monsieur que c'était un
endroit sacré citan d'une d une chapelle
personnelle de la reine ça fait partie
du chapelle royale de la vaunage sur
l'angleterre c'est là que tout va se
gâter
édouard le confesseur a dont été et
intérêts donc c'est un endroit où il ya
une très longue lignée depuis la
conquête des normands si on peut dire au
xième siècle qui ont bâti cette
7,4
cette cathédrale qui était une abeille
enfin une abbaye qui était un homme
finalement un autre religieux
bénédictins qui voit les anciens premier
ministre de grande bretagne
donc ça c'est le coin des anciens
premiers ministres ils ont été répartis
comme ça dans le mini un peu selon et il
ya une partie pour le commonwealth et
une partie pour les anciens premiers
ministres pour les
royautés les têtes couronnées également
mais c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
pour le dire aux termes familiers la
marque
britannique attire encore danser que ces
pays là on était des colonies ils
veulent être aux funérailles et même la
chaîne on évoquait en fin de semaine
dans les journaux ou trois semaines on
évoquait le fait que u2 guerre de
l'opium en chine la grande-bretagne
et les chinois littéralement et
quand même les héritiers de ça c'est à
dire le régime de saint jean ping ils
veulent être là et ces mêmes poutine
vous avez vous aussi il s'est offusqué
qu'on ne le dit pas il ya des emplois il
terme d'asf et matois ce qui est
grandement excessif il ya de bonnes
raisons de pas l'éviter franchement mais
il reste que les gens tonnait être là
quelles que soient les régimes y compris
les dictatures toutes les têtes
couronnées ballet ya des affinités dont
on pourra parler mais il ya 2 une force
d'attraction c'est pas un pays si riche
et à coopérer avec les etats-unis une
force d'attraction c'est comme recevoir
une espèce de brevets j'ai été aux
funérailles de la reine puis j'ai eu
cette ardeur et c'est quand même
étonnant parce que cette femme n'avait
aucun pouvoir politique va pouvoir
symbolique elle avait un sens un point
pouvoirs protocolaires oui elle avait
aucun pouvoir elle régnait elle ne
gouverne pas mais il reste que justement
le fait de ne pas gouverner mais
seulement renier si je peux dire comme
ça et elle avait aussi une plus grande
marge de manoeuvre a pas de discuter
avec ses premiers ministres de tous les
sujets possibles et impossibles et de
donner son opinion évidemment en privé
et on sait très bien que aucun de ce
premier ministre a jamais de vue que
lier quoi que ce soit de ces rencontres
et je suis certaine que la reine aux
emmys son opinion sur un nombre
incroyable de sujets mais c'est resté un
discussion privée et c'est ce que on lui
reconnaissait c'est qu'elle était
toujours d'une
porte l'événement elle avait toujours ce
set train de trahir sérénité face à ce
qui se passait et toujours avec un mot
d'espoir on l'a vu lors de son dernier
discours à la nation sur la pandémie on
va se revoir google meet again donc
c'était vraiment donner de l'espoir aux
gens et le peuple vraiment c'est ce
qu'ils veulent retenir de cette
souveraine c'est cette
sérénité qu'elle a été capable de
redonner à tout le monde le
l'espoir en font que les choses vont
s'améliorer alors là là pour le roi
charles ii continue et 7 cette façon de
faire
être vont lui demander beaucoup vers
olivier vous avez passé 35 ans à londres
donc vous connaissez bien
cet attachement en fait des anglais des
britanniques alors rennes c'était
incroyable ce qu'on l'a vu pendant les
derniers jours je sais c'est que d'une
centaine de milliers de personnes qui
ont attendu des heures de temps dans le
froid la nuit le jour à toute heure du
jour et la nuit en fête pour pouvoir se
recueillir devant son cercueil il ya
tout un ensemble d'éléments c'est sûr il
ya vraiment quelque chose qui est dans
les tripes des britanniques à tout le
système des pandas rennes tout remonte à
la au monarque donc ça c'est été
appris dlt la petite enfance si on peut
dire et les gens ont dit qu'en lien
d'affection et c'est sûr que la reine
était devenu comme une grand-mère pour
tout le monde en plus avec son âge cette
cette façon d'être qui était toujours
positive toujours mon orgue et
rassembleuse aussi elle a quand même
beaucoup évolué pour ouvrir et être sûr
d'inclure tous les britanniques qui sont
quand même nathan très multiculturelle à
la société britannique et c'est très
très très mélangées et donc qu'elle a
fait très attention je pense que ça a
été le grand changement pour la
monarchie cette réinvention d'être de
faire très attention à tous à tous et
son patronage de un très grand nombre de
l'organisation caritative l'a perdue lui
a permis d'être en contact aussi avec
les besoins réels de
d2 anglaise tous les jours
mais c'est sûr que c'est un attachement
qui est viscérale que essai serait
difficile et certainement charles n'a
pas conquis encore l'écart de cette
façon là haut niveau on parlait tout à
l'heure au niveai la façon dont il va
interagir est-ce qui va parce que lui il
est quand même assez en ligne avec hull
le courant du moment sur l'environnement
par exemple il a été pendant ministre
justin trudeau et sophie grégoire son
épouse dont qui arrivent à westminster à
l'abbaye de westminster pour ses
funérailles parce que évidemment après
l'hommage des britanniques après
l'hommage des gens disons plus ordinaire
c'est maintenant l'hommage à la chef
d'état par tous ces dignitaires par le
monde en fait qui vient lui rendre un
dernier hommage je vais retrouver rafael
bouvier auclair qui se trouve à hyde
park un peu plus à l'ouest où on va
diffuser la cérémonie sur grand écran
c'est toujours un lieu de rassemblement
important on attend beaucoup de monde
raphaël
oui il ya déjà beaucoup de gens qui sont
arrivés dans ce grand parc de londres
celle et nous on est effectivement
installés de nombreux écrans juste
autour de moi j'en vois environ 7 et y
en a qui sont installés ailleurs dans le
parc donc on va diffuser ses funérailles
d'état sur cet écran il ya des gens
évidemment qu'ils ont voulu être encore
plus près des lieux où tout ça se passe
du centre de long du palais de
buckingham de l'abbaye de wesminster
donc des gens qui ont trempé j'en ai vu
hier soir en prenant dans la capitale
qui veulent être vraiment premières
loges ici les gens ont pris un peu de
recul et sont venus parfois en famille
avec pique nique avec des fleurs qui
pourraient être déposées entre autres
ici à hyde park à green park à côté
aussi où il ya des arrangements floraux
que l'on a vus grandir et grandir au
cours des derniers jours donc ce sont
des gens qui viennent parfois de
l'étranger évidemment beaucoup du
royaume uni mais de partout au pays
tout à l'heure on a parlé à des gens qui
venaient de newcastle de manchester
d'aussi loin que de l'irlande du nord
qui voulait être dans la capitale pour
assister à ce qu'ils décrivent comme
étant évidemment un moment d'histoire
pour leur pays un c'est une changement
d'époque tous les gens à qui on a parlé
finalement n'ont connu que la reine
elizabeth comme mon arc au cours de leur
vie donc beaucoup d'inconnues à venir
mais aujourd'hui c'était surtout
l'occasion de revenir sur la vie de
celle qui a été à la tête de l'état
pendant 70 ans voici quelques
commentaires qu'on a recueilli 6 ipad
[Musique]
oui alors on a assez longs délais avec
vous raphaël on s'excuse mais donc les
gens
cassés ému endeuillées qui sont là et
qui veulent participer ils veulent
peuvent être là pour cet événement
pendant qu'on voit les images du roi
charles qui sourit riches vers l'ouest
de l'abbaye de wesminster alesi
est tout à fait images qui sont
retransmises donc ici derrière nous ce
qui explique peut être possible des
lèvres parce qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens qui
utilisent leur téléphone portable
évidemment avant que ses funérailles
d'état ne commence donc des gens qui ont
voulu je voulais venir assister à ces
événements beaucoup de gens ici qui
portent des décorations militaires
évidemment qu accorde une importance
particulière à la reine est intéressant
pour s'être promené dans la région de
londres céline au cours des derniers
jours de constater un certain contraste
entre ce qui se passe ici au coeur de la
capitale près de tous ces monuments où
on revient sur la vie de la reine où on
lui rend hommage et ce qui se passe dans
d'autres quartiers qui sont parfois
davantage en périphérie ou en quelque
sorte la vie continue aujourd'hui c'est
une journée qui est férié on s'est rendu
dans le sud de londres aussi où il ya
des quartiers particulièrement
défavorisés qui sont très touchés par la
crise économique que traverse le royaume
uni en ce moment avec une inflation de
près de 10% et la base qu'on disait
s'écouter ce n'est n'est pas notre
priorité nous ce qu'on tente de faire en
ce moment c'est de payer nos factures de
fermes face à l'inflation de faire face
à la hausse importante des prix de
l'énergie et c'est ça le défi principal
qui occupe l'esprit des gens ce moment
donc beaucoup moins ce qui se passe ici
au coeur de londres est clairement ici à
hyde park aujourd'hui la priorité c'est
de rendre hommage à la reine elizabeth
donc les gens se retrouvent dans le parc
et en a certains qui vont tenter de
bouger à la fin de la cérémonie puisque
rares vous savez une procession dans les
de l'ombre et qui va se terminer non
loin d'ici au coin de notre pack de
l'ipad pardon pour ce qui est de la
portion londonienne il y aura un petit
mouvement de foule à la fin de ses
funérailles pour aller voir ce qui se
passe de l'autre côté poids qui a déjà
énormément de gens il s'est pas dit que
les gens qui sont ici vont réussir à
accéder à la route de ce portage de
cette procession on va vous parler des
gens et de peut-être des réactions un
peu plus mitigé dans d'autres quartiers
de londres faut dire que évidemment tout
ça coûte assez cher sont les
contribuables qui vont devoir payer
beaucoup de gens se disaient est ce
qu'on aurait pu mettre l'argent ailleurs
avec toutes les difficultés que vivent
les britanniques en ce moment
oui exactement avec une inflation qui
est près de 10 % c'est le taux le plus
élevé de tous les pays du g7 il ya une
énorme débat sur le prix des factures
d'électricité d'ailleurs le parlement
britannique vous savez débattait de ces
enjeux lorsque on a appris la nouvelle
de la mort de la reine et ses débats
politiques ont en quelque sorte été
suspendu pour cette période de deuil
mais il ya des gens qui s'attendent à
des actions concrètes de la part du
gouvernement pour pouvoir les aider à
traverser les prochains mois prochains
mois qui seront évidemment plus froids
qui nécessiteront davantage d'énergie
comment va-t-on payer pour ça alors il
ya une espèce de dualité effectivement
entre ce qui se produit en ce moment
avec ses cérémonie très officielle et
puis la réalité des gens qui doivent
penser à tout simplement payer leurs
factures douce et kitty qu'on a pu
entendre oui même s'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui formuler des critiques mais qui
disait à la fois respecter la reine donc
on a entendu avant toutes sortes
d'opinions dans la région de londres au
cours des derniers jours comme quoi ya
pas une pensée unique à l'endroit de la
monarchie des cérémonies et de tout ce
qui tourne autour bien sûr merci
beaucoup raphaël
pendant qu'on voit les images du roi
charles iii donc qu'ils arrivent à
westminster il nous on retrouve notre
catherine gauthier qui est juste devant
l'abbaye de westminster devant le
portail donc on va passer le cercueil de
la reine devait déjà vu passer de
nombreux dignitaires catherine
absolument et je peux vous dire céline
que le roi arrive tout près de moi je
peux le voir ici derrière ce qui veut
dire que on va pouvoir voir cette
procession ce cortège qui va se rendre
ici l abbaye de westminster le départ
est prévu à 10h44 précisément heure de
londres donc au cours des prochaines
minutes tout ça va se mettre en branle
et je vous dirais que encore une fois ce
qui frappe c'est line comme cette
semaine c'est le silence autour de nous
vous allez entendre la cloche de wes
masters qui sonne chaque minute voilà 96
fois encore une fois pour souligner les
96 années de vie de la reine elizabeth 2
alors les dignitaires qui arrivent ici
depuis huit heures ce matin heure de
londres on a vu bien sûr le président
français emmanuel macron le président
américain joe biden justin trudeau qui
est arrivé aussi
de même que eux d'anciens premiers
ministres britanniques entre autres
boris johnson qui sait aussi on parle de
2010 ni terre plus d'une centaine de
chefs d'état et de gouvernement ce qui
fait que la sécurité on le voit on le
sent ici c'est très très très très serré
on a dû arriver très tôt en fait dans la
nuit pour pouvoir se rendre jusqu'ici de
notre hôtel jusqu'à l'abbaye de
westminster ici parce que évidemment ça
prend de sécurité extraordinaire d'une
part pour recevoir tous ces gens là d'un
peu partout je faisais les rangs un
instant catherine parce qu'on vient
d'apercevoir dans cette voiture le les
dix arrière petits enfants de la reine
donc les princes le prince george et la
princesse charlotte 9 ans 7 ans qui vont
participer à cette procession un peu
plus tard à ce cortège oui et ça risque
de raviver certains douloureux souvenirs
on va penser évidemment au prince harry
et william qui marchaient derrière le
cortège cercueil de leur mère iulia
quelques années je vous ai interrompu
allez-y d'ailleurs le presse oui le
prince william qui le dit d'ailleurs
cette semaine parce qu'il a fait cette
première procession du palais de
buckingham jusqu'ici à westminster hall
et il le dit de marché dans ce cortège
derrière le cercueil de sa grand mère ça
lui rappelait ses douloureux souvenirs
lorsque sa mère est morte il ya
plusieurs années il était encore enfant
donc cette procession là vous l'avez dit
donc la princesse charlotte et le prince
george vous rencontriez leurs parents
les nouveaux princes et princesses de
galles donc william et kate middleton
bien sûr aussi le prince harry sera là
avec megan mais aussi les quatre enfants
de la reine ce sera menée par le roi
charles iii avec la reine consort mais
aussi la princesse anne les princes
andrew et edward qui seront dans cette
procession qui va donc se déplacer jusqu
ici jusqu'à l'entrée de l'abbaye de
westminster oui ça faisait quatre jours
et vous avez suivi toutes ces journées
ces longues journées où on suivait cette
chapelle ardente à westminster hall ça
s'est donc terminée il ya quelques
heures là c'était assez émouvant en fait
ça se terminer juste avant qu'on prépare
l'abbaye
pour cette cérémonie qui va se dérouler
maintenant dans une vingtaine de minutes
et pendant ces quatre jours là on a vu
défiler nous des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui faisaient la file pour
accéder à cette chapelle ardente pour se
recueillir plusieurs nous ont confié
avoir entendu sans trop d'impatience
parce qu'on voulait remercier la reine
on voulait passer devant son cercueil
pour ses soixante dix ans de règne des
gens de tous âges qui dès qu'ils
traversaient le pont la bête pour se
rendre de ce côté-ci de la tamise devenu
un peu plus silencieux se recueillaient
davantage même si plusieurs ont fait des
rencontres bien sûr presque 14 15 heures
d'attentes même pour se rendre à cette
chapelle ardente alors ça c'est terminé
on affirmer la file cette nuit s'est
terminée ce matin à 6h30 par
le passage de celle qu'on appelle la
dame 8 hier du bâton noir donc c'est un
protocole c'est elle qui a été la
dernière à s'incliner devant le cercueil
de la reine elizabeth 2 alors qu'on me
dit que des gens commencent à arriver
donc ici derrière moi alors je pense que
c'est la reine consort qui arrive tout
juste derrière à l'entrée de westminster
abbey pendant qu'on prépare le cortège
de l'autre côté donc cette dame lice
hier du bâton noir tout juste avant elle
c'était une britannique qui a réalisé
qu'elle était la dernière à avoir plus
s'incliner devant le cercueil de la
reine je pense qu'on peut l'inde
ça me va
non
ce qui est mis à manier sans lourdes
oui émouvant quand même pour cette
personne de penser qu'elle est qu'elle a
été la dernière à pouvoir se recueillir
devant le cercueil de la reine alors
vous le disais on l'a vu arriver la
reine consort on l'a vu rentrer dans
l'abbaye de westminster et l'os qu'on
voit ce sont les marins donc parce que
ce sont des marins qui vont tirer la
fugue un an avec le cercueil de la reine
pour cette procession s'est évaporé on
aurait pu penser que ça aurait été des
chevaux mais non ce sont des des jeunes
membres de la marine royale 142 marin
qui vont qui vont le faire et puis
j'avais une question pour vous
catherine parce que on disait que les
chefs d'états les dignitaires allait
arriver par autobus et non pas par des
voitures particulières parce que ç'a
bien été le cas
absolument des autocars c'est rare qu'on
voit ça aussi mais quand on pense aux
périmètres c'est tellement serré est
tellement fermé céline que c'était sans
doute la meilleure façon de pouvoir les
faire arriver ici hawass mais tu donc
oui des autocars qui ont amené les
dignitaires par groupe par différents
groupes depuis depuis 8h ce matin donc
heure de londres pour venir assister à
cet événement qui est un événement
historique et on le sent et si céline on
sent toute l'importance toute la
fébrilité des gens qui réalisent là
qu'ils vont dire au revoir pour la
dernière fois alors rennes parce que
plusieurs d'entre eux n'ont pas n'ont
pas connu d'autres monarques donc ça
aussi ça faisait faire vraiment partie
de la vie des britanniques des gens du
royaume uni on l'entend du en écho à son
talent à édimbourg au début de la
semaine et les gens nous disaient ça
aussi
c'était important pour eux de la saluer
c'était un peu la stabilité du pays dans
les différentes crises qui ont été
traversés par les britanniques par les
gens du royaume uni alors oui vraiment
on sent ça aujourd'hui alors que on
entendrait manque le circuit va bientôt
se sortir de là voilà une rue derrière
nous
alors il devrait passer bientôt derrière
nous avec cette procession donc vous le
disiez 142 membres de la marine qui sont
arrivés un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
aussi tout autour de la place du
parlement alors le cercueil de la reine
qui avait posé dessus la couronne est
vraiment impérial le sceptre et l'orb
ainsi qu une couronne de fleurs de
couleur rose jusqu'ici on avait vu
beaucoup de deux camps de fleurs
blanches
aujourd'hui des fleurs de couleur oui
donc ce cercueil qui va être déposée sur
l'affût de canon et la procession va se
mettre en branle de westminster hall
jusqu'à l'abbaye de westminster
absolument
comme nous à 1242 marin c'est une
tradition qui date des funérailles de la
reine victoria
à l'époque l'homme un des câbles qui
tirait
la fidh canaux qui étaient reliés au
chapeau s'est brisé et le prince louis
ii battenberg rapidement pris la
décision de demander à démarrer de tirer
le canon avec des cordes et la tradition
c'est toujours perpétué le pur à chacun
des achats qu'une des funérailles des
des monarques par la suite donc vers la
tradition audi même si vous permettez
est celle que les chevaux ont paniqué et
glisser sur la glace c'était pour les
funérailles de la victoria ils sont fils
édouard cet été là et c'est en effet
c'est louise battenberg qui a proposé
cette solution qui est à l'iccat passe
question on employait les chevaux ça ne
fonctionnerait pas alors on s'est aperçu
qu'il y avait quelque chose de
prestigieux là dedans à ce que ce soit
des marins apte à la force de leurs bras
kitty l'affût de canon et on regardait
que cette tradition en effet et on ne
pas lire parce qu'il faut le poly
régulièrement parce que sinon lire ou
vont devons devenir valent alors il faut
les roulis de temps en temps c'était le
canon qui très vieux alors on a
entretenu cette cet instrument thomas
ordre tout à l'heure
on va écouter quelques instants vous
apercevez la famille royale donc il est
déjà en place derrière le cercueil de la
reine
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va le rejoindre catherine dernière
fois qu'on nous parlait de cette
procession parce que elle va passer
juste à côté d'elle catherine donc c'est
très courant ces quelques quelques
minutes parce que c'est quoi ces 150
mètres à peu prend
à peu près au maximum parce que là je
vois donc les chevaux qui sont tout
juste devant le cortège donc qui sont
devant la procession et les cornemuses
alors le bien sûr le cercueil qui suit
donc toute cette procession pour le
début de cette cérémonie écoutez c'est
avec la cloche encore qui sonne c'est un
moment incroyable leurs cellules et on
sent les gens ici sont rivés vers vers
ce cortège vers cette profession qui est
bien sûr aussi monnet ambuehl a des vues
sur les images par le roi charles iii sa
soeur ses deux frères ses deux fils et
ses deux petits enfants aussi
l'appréciation charlotte et le prince
george alors voilà
je crois que les deux enfants ce sera un
petit peu plus tard parce que
je pense que ça va être dans l'habillage
je ne les aperçoit pas pour le moment
donc ce sera pour peut-être une autre de
ces processions parce qu'évidemment il y
aura ensuite le cercueil sera où sera
parader à nouveau dans les rideaux
andres après la sérénade oui et on verra
une soros et deux enfants quand même
neuf ans 7 ans c'est pas prévu pour
participer à ce genre de processus ils
sont arrivés avec
même voiture que la famille concernée
via et la princesse de galles dont ils
sont déjà à la bi
je voulais vous signaler que la marine
qui est mise à contribution maintenant
est un symbole fort de la monarchie ces
deux signaux forts s'étaient est-il si
vous voulez le corps militaire dans
lesquelles la famille royale il plus
impliqué il faut rappeler que la reine
et où automatiquement première mira de
la flotte que le prince philippe a été
lui-même commandant d'une partie de la
flotte à malte notamment qui l'amène
brillante carrière qui s'annonçait dans
la marine et que le dernier qu'ils
finirent une funérailles de ce genre sur
un affût canaux avec ce groupe de marins
c'est winston churchill qui à son époque
a été premier lors de la mi-août et
alors il ya eu toute une tradition puis
il est tout un symbole du web ce sont
des marais qui transporte la dépouille
de la reine et de certains membres de
familles royales ça a été quand la reine
victoria aussi
évidemment c'est un cortège cette
procession tout a été minutieusement
préparée depuis des années envers ans ça
fait des années qu'on prépare ses
funérailles caen caen
on a répété depuis plusieurs jours
exactement comment là ça allait se
passer et on peut aimer ou ne pas aimer
la monarchie mais on doit leur quand
même reconnaître cette cette façon de
faire qui date peut-être d'un autre
siècle mais d'un autre âge mais quand
même qui donne des images très
impressionnantes absolument des images
qui sont très impressionnants très
émotionnel la fête touche même si on
n'est pas de l'artiste quand on voit ces
mouvements de troupe à cette
recueillement si on peut tomber cette
discipline aussi tout autour d'
événement comme ça y'a pas n'est pas une
ligne de travers tout est vraiment
répétés en ce sens c'est un sit-in
chauffe-eau
monstration disait mon sens une force et
ça dans la science si c'est ça fait
partie du rejet total à la gran via
bruxelles n'a cessé c'est ce qui va
attirer aussi continuer d'attirer le
tourisme ne peut pas tout ça ça fait
partie de l'image du royaume uni à
l'étranger et donc quelque chose qui
perpétue aussi cet engouement pour la
monarchie pour des choses qui se fait
d'une manière extrêmement d'heure on a
aperçu le prince harry donc qui n'est
pas en uniforme un but qui leur est
nominé renoncer à ses devoirs royaux
donc le prince harry et le prince andrew
ne l'est pas non plus les pandas aperçu
en uniforme quand il est allé pour la
vigie du prince oui mais c'était la
seule fois toutes les deux
le prince joue avec ses deux vrais leroy
son frère le prince édouard et la
princesse anne il était en uniforme est
de même lorsque les petits enfants de la
reine en fait cette vigile le prince
harry était en uniforme mais c'était à
prévoir que pour le général il serait
en civil ils portent à leur médaille
mais ils sont en civil la princesse anne
et en uniforme de la marine tout comme
les membres importants de la famille
royan c'est le cas du nouveau roi une
forme de la marine certains on va
certainement porter l'uniforme de
l'aviation celui qui comme un bleu bleu
clair un peu là certains ne porte encore
aujourd'hui me semble-t-il alors il se
distribuent les génies forme suivant les
différents corps militaires du pays
l'abbaye de westminster où va se
dérouler cette cérémonie qui va
commencer dans huit minutes maintenant
je crois qu'on a le temps d'aller
retrouver à z vol de leur glisse donc
toujours à londres à z un petit mot sur
ces gens là qui attendent avec
impatience la prochaine procession ans
est celle qui va suivre la cérémonie
oui céline écouter les gens attendent
depuis très longtemps ses funérailles
d'état donc il ya des milliers de
personnes qui sont sur le long des
routes parce qu'évidemment le cercueil
de la reine va passer sur le mall vers
buckingham palace avant de se rendre au
château de windsor mis en service cette
reine elle a marqué le coeur des
britanniques mais aussi les politiciens
parce qu'une des choses que la plupart
d'entre eux ont raconté ces camps fait
chaque fois à chaque premier ministre
qu'elle a rencontré chaque semaine
pendant une demi-heure et discuter et la
reine comme elle n'accorde jamais
d'entrevue il se confier à elle est
beaucoup de chefs d'état se sont confiés
à elle que ce soit en europe que ce soit
en amérique du nord et elle a toujours
gardé les confidences pour elle elle les
aura gardé jusqu'à la mort et c'est
aussi ça qui est un peu célébré
aujourd'hui c'est que chaque chef d'état
estimé que c'était un peu la seule
personne qui n'était pas vraiment
politique mais qui était un peu au delà
des politiques et c'est ce que l'ancien
premier ministre tony blair disait le
premier ministre pouvait être émotif
pouvait être triste heureux il savait
que la reine elle était là et qu'elle le
gardait tout pour elle en fait donc
c'est ça aussi qui a fait la différence
de sets monarque par rapport à d'autres
chefs d'état si vous voulez et puis pour
les gens aussi pour le public aussi
chaque personne qu'on a rencontrés se
souvenait de la seule minute qu'ils ont
pu passer avec elle ses wc fameux bain
de foule qu'elle faisait pendant ses 70
ans de règne l aller dans les villages
encore c'est gordon parti s'est un peu
tous ces gens là qui sont sur la route
aujourd'hui pour lui dire merci puis
chacun se souvient de ce que ce qu'elle
leur a dit donc ce qui est intéressant
avec la reine que c'est chaque individu
s'est senti un peu unique au monde pour
un instant avec elle et c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont tous arrivés si vous voulez
sur les routes sur le long des routes à
londres pour lui dire un derrière un
derrière un dernier au revoir pardon en
fait il avait comme une relation
personnelle avec elle on va entendre
certains d'entre eux
silent
way même les gens qui ne veulent pas
exprimé leur émotion en laissant assez
ému et un peu à peu sombre aussi parce
qu'évidemment c'est la dernière fois
qu'ils vont pouvoir lui rendre hommage
et on parlait beaucoup de la sécurité un
dispositif exceptionnel mais est ce
qu'on la sent vraiment
oui on la sent partout vraiment les
policiers sont partout mais ils sont
quand même assez discret on les voit on
sent leur présence parce qu'il faut
assurer la sécurité de tous les chefs
d'état mais aussi des personnalités
politiques ici en grande bretagne et ils
veulent surtout pas rater leur coup là
ils ont dit c'est leur réputation qui
est en jeu vous mentionnez tout à
l'heure avec catherine savez ces fameux
autobus là qu'ils ont transportés à tous
les dignitaires vers l'abbaye de
wesminster alors il ya eu certain prince
était froid c'est de devoir prendre le
bus en disant même que est ce que le
est-ce que vous aurez laissé le roi
charles prendre un autobus le seul qui a
pu assurer son propre transports c'est
le président baden qui va partir
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs donc je pense que
les services de sécurité vont pousser un
soupir de soulagement mais c'est sûr que
londres est sûre en état d' alerte sur
un pied d'alerté est vraiment il ya non
seulement des policiers il ya des
militaires 2000 militaires dix mille
policiers également des bénévoles et
puis aussi les policiers qui sont en
civil un qui se mêlent dans la foule
mais ils ont dit que leurs principaux
alliés c'est le public ces millions de
personnes qui sont le long des routes
ils leur ont dit le message est très
clair de scotland yard si vous voyez
quelque chose de suspect appelez aller
voir un policier si vous voyez un paquet
suspect ou n'importe quoi prévenez nous
vous êtes nos yeux vous êtes nos
oreilles évidemment que vous le savez si
vis de la grande bretagne a une grande
expérience se souvient des attentats de
noël et de l'irlande du nord dans les
années 70 donc ils sont habitués à se
surveiller entre six lettres merci
beaucoup à z on va aller maintenant
regardez écoutez un peu vous voyez le
cercueil qui va rentrer dans l'abbaye de
voici
[Musique]
donc à un moment assez émouvant cette
cérémonie
quand on dit fastueuse exceptionnelle
elle va commencer elle devrait être
relativement forte autour de 55 minutes
elle sera dirigée par le doyen de
westminster on attend aussi des discours
de la nouvelle première ministre liste
rose de la secrétaire général du
commonwealth patricia scotland le sermon
sera prononcée par l'archevêque de
canterbury le primat de l'église
d'angleterre et puis deux minutes de
silence dans tout le royaume uni vont la
conclure cette cérémonie qui sera
également retransmise sur des écrans
géants et dans les cinémas à travers le
pays alors on va écouter ça ensemble
[Musique]
hu
ce
[Musique]
oh
et
là
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
auj
[Musique]
et
ça
chan
[Musique]
non
oh
assez haut
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
le
et
à
ça
[Musique]
et
ans
[Musique]
chevaux
chan
[Musique]
oh
rousseau
[Musique]
oh
voilà
[Musique]
oh
et
j'm'en
les amants
[Musique]
oh
faux
[Musique]
oh
à
ça
oh
[Musique]
à
et
sans
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
à
ingrid
alors prions ensemble
dans une église où l'espoir et les
mémoires sont des devoirs sacrés ici où
la reine elizabeth a été marié couronné
nous sommes réunis tous ici de partout
dans la nation du commonwealth et des
nations du monde pour
penser à notre perte pour nous souvenir
de sa vie dévouée aux autres et
nous la remettons entre les mains de
dieu notre créateur et avec gratitude
nous nous souvenons de son engagement au
fil des années en tant que reine et chef
du commonwealth avec admiration nous
nous souvenons de son sens du devoir
tout au long de sa vie et de son
dévouement envers les gens et avec
gratitude et reconnaissance nous
remercions dieu pour son exemple
constant de foi chrétienne et de
dévouement et avec beaucoup d'affection
nous nous souvenons de son amour pour sa
famille et son engagement envers les
causes qui lui étaient chers et
maintenant en silence en nos coeurs et
nos esprits
souvenons nous de toutes ces raisons
pour lesquelles nous avons de la
reconnaissance prions pour les membres
de sa famille et
je demande à ce que la reine elisabeth
soit dans les soins du créateur
or massif encore
dieu empli de mercy le père de
jésus-christ qui est le résurrection et
la vie est ainsi
tous ceux qui croient vivront malgré les
décès et ceux qui croit en lui ne me
rends pas éternellement et il nous
envoie zee il nous a appris par le biais
de saint paul de ne pas
d'être bien parce que ceux qui dorment
en lui sont sauvés
et lorsque nous quitterons cette vie
nous pouvons nous reposer en créer dans
le créateur
et cela à la résurrection général aux
derniers jours
nous pouvons recevoir la bénédiction
reçu du fils adoré
vienne vient enfin béni de mon père
reçoivent le royaume de dieu qui a été
préparé pour toi depuis le début des
jours
et par le biais de jésus-christ notre
médiateur notre
sauveur
[Musique]
je
non
maintenant le seigneur s'est levée des
ténèbres
et il est devenu le premier fruit de
ceux qui dorment
et
de l'homme via la mare
de l'homme aussi bien que la
résurrection des hommes 1 1 2 et où
comme
pourra dans tout ce kit est
dans le christ tous seront vivants
seront rendus vivants mais chaque homme
à son art
howard et chris de les premiers fruits
et ses hommes qui deviennent christ à sa
venue
comme et ainsi vient où l'a fait
lorsqu'il leur a
livré le royaume adieu le royaume à son
père et lorsqu'il leur a
un port remis toute autorité et pouvoir
parce qu'il doit régner
il doit régner et le dernier ennemi
qui sera détruit c'est la mort
puisque
les corruptibles
doivent faire face de cette corruption
et les mortels
doivent prendre l'immortalité sur soi
et quand c'est
corruptible
et c'est mortel autres auront
été vers l'immortalité
alors
et sur le dans ce mortel hors harvey
d'ci l'immortalité alors s'accomplira la
parole qui est écrite la mort a été
engloutie dans la victoire aux morts où
est ton aiguillant au tombeau où est ta
victoire
l'aiguillon de la mort c'est le péché et
la force du péché c'est la loi
mais grâce soit rendue à dieu qui nous
donne la victoire
par notre seigneur jésus-christ
et c'est pourquoi
mes frères et soeurs bien aimé soyez
ferme
soyez
inébranlable soyez persévérant dans
l'oeuvre du seigneur sachant que votre
travail
n'est pas vain dans le seigneur
merci
à dieu
[Musique]
oh
sow
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
m
hu
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
o o
[Musique]
ça
on s'assied propos
[Musique]
sow
et ça
[Musique]
vva
[Applaudissements]
soit
[Musique]
oh
à
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
ne laissez pas votre coeur être troublé
vous croyez en moi vous croyez dans la
maison du seigneur sont plusieurs
maisons et six noeuds il ya plusieurs
demeures s'ils n'en étaient pas ici je
vous l'aurais dit je vais vous préparez
une place ici je vais vous préparez une
classe je reviendrai et je vous recevrez
chez moi afin que là où je suis vous y
soyez aussi et vous savez où je vais et
vous connaissez le chemin
thomas lui dit seigneur nous ne savons
pas où de suiveurs et comment
pouvons-nous connaître le chemin
jésus lui dit je suis le chemin la
vérité et la vie nul ne vient on perd
que par mois
si vous m'aviez connu vous auriez aussi
connu mon père est désormais vous le
connaissez
et vous l'avez vu
philippe lui dit seigneur
montre nous le père et cela nous suffit
jésus lui dit il y a si longtemps que je
suis avec toi et ne pas connu philippe
celui qui m'a vu à vue le père
grâce soit rendue à dieu
[Musique]
il
et
oh
ils sont
[Musique]
non
comme l'histoire
vient saint-esprit et remplit nos coeurs
avec le bol
de votre amour amen
chaque semaine il y 2 alors pour
plusieurs
leaders c'est d'être
emplis de vie puis oublié après la mort
alors
c'est ainsi pour ceux qui servent dieu
qui soit connu ou obscurs respecter ou
ignorer
la porte et
la mort et la porte de la gloire notre
majesté maintenant décédée a dit lors de
ses 21 ans que toute sa vie serait
dévoué au service de la nation et du
commonwealth est très rarement
est ce qu'une telle promesse a été tenue
très peu de leaders
reçoivent
autant d'amour que nous avons vu dès
lors de son règne et dans les derniers
jours et jésus
ne dit pas aux disciples comment le
suivre mais qui suivent et a dit je suis
le chemin je suis la vérité je suis la
vie
l'exemple de sa majesté
n'a pas été
un reflet de sa position et de son
ambition mais deux qui l a suivi et je
sais que sa majesté
partage la foi en jésus-christ tout
comme sa mère
elle a aussi un sens du devoir qui lui
vient
des personnes qui l'ont précédé
l'apprennent a commencé son règne en
prière silencieuse ici devant l'hôtel et
son dévouement envers dieu
a commencé avant que toute autre
personne lui prêtent allégeance et le
services qu'elle a rendus en vert tant
de gens dans cette nation et dans ce
monde étaient fondées dont le fait
qu'elle suivait le christ dieu lui même
qui a dit
qu'il est venu non pas pour être servi
mais afin de servir et pour donner sa
vie
un rançon pour celle de tant d'autres et
les gens qui se dévouent au service sont
rares
les leaders qui se dévouent au service
sont encore plus rares mais dans tous
les cas ceux qui servent
seront aimés on s'en souviendra alors
que d'autres qui s'accrocheront pouvoir
seront rapidement oublier le deuil de ce
jour qui est ressenti non seulement par
la famille de notre majesté mais par des
gens à travers le monde à travers le
connaît mme commonwealth sont inspirés
de sa vie abondante et de tous les
services qu'elle a rendus
elle était empli de joie elle était
présente elle toucher les gens et nous
prions aujourd'hui pour toute sa famille
en deuil et comme toute autre famille au
moment des funérailles
et pensons aussi à toutes ces familles à
travers le monde qui ont récemment perdu
un être cher
mais dans le cas de cette famille en
particulier
ils sont sous la lumière
des médias
et nous demandons que les souvenirs
qu'ils sauront de sa majesté soit teinté
de la joie et de tout ce qu'elle leur a
apporté
sa majesté a dit nous nous verrons de
nouveaux qui viennent d'une chanson de
vera lynn l'espoir chrétiens
implique des attentes par rapport à ceux
qui n'a pas encore été vu le christ
élevé des morts et offrent eux la vie
éternelle à tous la vie abondante
maintenant mais aussi la vie avec dieu
dans l'éternité
et comme les chants de noël le disent
c'est lorsque les âmes le reçoivent
oui le christ demeure
et chacun à notre tour nous ferons face
au jugement empli de merci de dieu
et nous pouvons tous partager l'espoir
de la reine dans la vie et dans la mort
c'est rennes qui était inspiré à tout
moment qui a servi pendant sa vie qui a
manifesté l'espoir face à la mort et
donc nous tous qui suivant l'exemple de
la reine de sa foi en dieu
oui peuvent dire avec elle nous nous
rencontrerons de nouveau
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
aïe
m
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
au nord
c'est heroes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
in computer and trust à la confiance
là est la confidence prix
rendant grâce à dieu pour la longue vie
et le règne de la reine elizabeth
rappelant avec gratitude
ces dons de sagesse de diligence et de
services
aux dieux
pour les dons de coeur et d'esprit que
tu accordes et à ta fille
de qui accepte et les remerciements pour
les dons de carre d'esprit que tu as
accordé à ta fille
elisabeth et qu'elle a manifesté
parmi nous par ses paroles et ses actes
et à cordes et nous la grâce de vivre
nos vies
conformément à votre volonté
de rechercher le bien des autres
et de rester des serviteurs fidèles
jusqu'à la fin de notre vie par
jésus-christ notre seigneur amène
complète
une corde confiant dans l'amour et la
compassion de dieu
prions pour ceux dont le coeur est lourd
deux chats gré
et de douleurs
aux côtes dieu tout-puissant
père de toutes les miséricordes et
dispensateur de tout réconfort
épicier nous t'en prions
de ceux qui sont dans le deuil
afin qu'en rejetant sur toi tous leurs
soucis
ils puissent connaître la consolation de
ton amour
par jésus christ notre seigneur
me
brillon pour sa majesté le roi et pour
toute la famille royale afin qu'il
connaisse le pouvoir de soutien de
l'amour de dieu et la communion de
prière du peuple de dieu
le tout-puissant
source de toute bonté
nous te prions humblement de bénir notre
très grasse et souverain le roi charles
camilla la reine consort
william le prince de galles et toute la
famille royale
donne lors le saint-esprit
enrichi de ta grâce et laisse
feller prospérer tout le bonheur
possible et amène les dans ton royaume
éternel par jésus christ notre seigneur
amis
en reconnaissance des services rendus
par la reine elizabeth au royaume uni
réjouissons nous de son dévouement sans
faille à son devoir de sa compassion
pour ces sujets et des conseils qu'elle
prodigue à ses ministres et nous prions
pour la santé et la prospérité de cette
nation
dieu tout puissant dont la volonté est
que tous tes enfants te servent à ceux
servant les un réseau
regarde avec amour nous te prions cette
nuit nation accorde à ses citoyens la
grâce de travailler ensemble avec des
curse honnête et fidèle chacun se
souciant du bien de tous
afin que cherchant d'abord ton royaume
et sa justice il puisse posséder tout ce
qui est nécessaire à leur subsistance
quotidienne et au bien commun
par jésus-christ notre seigneur amine
à tous que
rendons grâce pour l'engagement de la
reine elizabeth envers le commonwealth
tout au long de son règne pour son
service et son dévouement envers ces
peuples et pour les riches liés d'unité
et de soutien mutuel qu'elle a
entretenue
au dieu tout puissant et éternel entend
notre prière pour la commonwealth et
accords de lui les conseils de ta
sagesse
inspire ce qui détiennent l'autorité
afin qu'ils puissent promouvoir la
justice et le bien commun
donne à toutes ses citoyens l'esprit
d'honneur et de respect mutuel
et accord de nous a tous la grâce de
lutter pour l'établissement de la
justice et de la paix
pour l'honneur de ton nom amen
beaucoup et ne nous rendons grâce à dieu
pour la filière élite et de la reine
elizabeth à la fois dont elle a hérité
pas son baptême et sa confirmation et
qu'elle a affirmé lors de son
couronnement
pour sa dévotion inébranlable à
l'évangile et pour son service in et
lambres à l'âme en tant que gouverneur
suprême de l'église d'angleterre
seigneur nous vous supplions de garder
votre maison l'église dans une piste et
continuelle afin que par votre
protection elles soient libres de toute
adversité et dévoué à vous servir dans
toutes les bonnes oeuvres à la gloire de
votre nom par jésus christ notre
seigneur amin
prions pour qu'il nous soit donnée la
grâce de vivre comme ceux qui croient à
la communion des saints au pardon des
péchés et à la résurrection pour la vie
éternelle
ah mais nous seigneur dieu à notre
dernier rêvait dans la maison et la
porte du ciel pour entrer dans cette
porte est habité dans cette maison
où il n'y aura ni ténèbres ni
éblouissement mais une égale lumière
ni bruit ni silence mais une égale
musique
ne fut ni crainte ni espoir mais une
égale possession
ni fin ni commencement
mais une égale éternité
dans la demeure de votre gloire et de
votre domination dans un monde sans fin
amen
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et
il comporte en travaux lara sprites de
fort engouement cv et rojas
prions pour
qu'il nous soit donnée la grâce de vifs
notre père qui êtes aux cieux que votre
nom soit sanctifié que votre règne
vienne que votre volonté soit faite sur
la terre comme au ciel donnez-nous
aujourd'hui notre pain quotidien
et pardonnez nous nos offenses comme
nous pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous
ont offensés
et ne nous soumettait pas la tentation
mais délivrez nous du mal car cet avocat
parti ne règnent la puissance et la
loire pour les siècles des siècles amen
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais non merci confions à la miséricorde
de dieu notre créateur et notre
rédempteur l'âme d'elisabeth notre
défunte reine
père céleste roi des rois seigneur et
dispensateur de l'année de vie qui par
votre grâce
a créé l'humanité à votre image et qui
dans votre grand amour nous offre la vie
éternelle dans le christ jésus
nous confions l'âme d'elisabeth
notre soeur ici décédé
à votre garde micro rico nuss dans
l'espoir sûr et certain de la
résurrection à la vie éternelle
lorsque le cri sera tout temps tous
lui qui est mort et ressuscité pour nous
sauver et qui maintenant vie et ring
avec vous et le saint-esprit dans la
gloire pour les siècles des siècles
de ce monde aux âmes chrétienne au nom
de dieu le père tout puissant qui vous a
créé au nom de jésus-christ fils du dieu
vivant qui a souffert pour toi au nom du
saint-esprit qui a été répandu sur toi
et ta on était
en communion avec toutes les saint béni
et avec l'aide des anges et des
archanges et de toutes les armées de la
1000 celle est-ce
que ta part soit aujourd'hui dans la
paix
et à demeure dans la jérusalem céleste
amin
[Musique]
faux
non
[Musique]
complet
oh
moi
[Musique]
oh
à
[Musique]
les gens
[Applaudissements]
à
j'ai pensé
bryce et
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va
et à
oh
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
que dieu accorde où vivent là grâce
au défunt le repos à l'église au roi au
commonwealth et à tous les peuples
la paix et la concorde
est à nous et pêcheurs la vie éternelle
que la bénédiction de dieu tout puissant
le père le fils et le saint-esprit m'en
sois parmi vous et demeure avec vous
pour toujours
amy
[Musique]
m
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
je
voilà c'est la fin de cette cérémonie
des funérailles de la reine elizabeth ii
une cérémonie qui aura duré un peu plus
longtemps que prévu donc plus une heure
et quart autour d'une heure et quart
cérémonie grandiose dans un cadre
vraiment fastueux de l'abbaye de
westminster vous avez vu ces images très
impressionnantes l'archevêque de
canterbury qui a fait l'éloge de la
reine en louant sa foi son engagement
son sens du service et du devoir et il
en a profité aussi pour signaler que
contrairement à la plupart des chefs
d'état du monde la reine elle a dédié sa
vie toute entière à sa mission il a dit
qu'elle était joyeuse présente pour tout
le monde et touchait qu'elle a touché
une multitude de vies alors révérend
olivier une cérémonie fastueuse mais
quand même assez traditionnel oui une
cérémonie dans laquelle beaucoup de
personnes de le désir et annick se
seront reconnus ont reconnu la définir
et de proches donc des gens qui étaient
très très connus qui font partie un peu
de l'inconscient collectif britannique
et donc ils auront permis à beaucoup de
se joindre justement parlera par la
pensée par parleurs une présence de loin
avec des déjections qu'ils auront
reconnu je voulais rajouter pour le lot
serment du de l'archevêque de canterbury
moi ce que j'ai noté quand même c'est un
message un peu codé enfin je sais pas
mais qu'il a dit je vais le dire en
anglais je vais te tuer mais deux ou
save will be remembered langast 2e kling
tout pas à ce bug aavb in the garden on
se souviendra de ceux qui ont servi bien
après ceux qui se sont raccrochés au
pouvoir s qui parlait à des trades
ministre britannique est ce qu'ils
parlent à d'autres cas cela j'en sais
rien mais c'est c'était quelque chose je
suis qui m'a qui m'a fait qui m'a fait
quand même
impression parce que dans ce contexte là
avec des chefs d'état des chefs d'état
qui sont peut-être d'enlever dans des
endroits ils sont pas forcément
aussi bien aimé que la reine est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui va faire
réfléchir j'en sais rien mais très très
très très belle cérémonie c'est sûr et
c'est toujours un endroit de
rassemblement dont qu'on a vues
différentes soit tradition chrétienne
mais aussi d'autres fois rassembler
rassembler la très importants symboles
britannique un pays très multi multi
culturelle comme on aime s'y est bien
sûr cérémonial avec les forces armées
très présente la précision des gestes la
beauté de la musique dit des anciennes
qui ont été composés pour l'occasion la
vue j'ai d'histoire mais aussi à james
mc mullen des très beau très beau très
belle composition actuelle donc c'est
toujours l'opportunité de montrer le
plus beau de ski se poster en angleterre
des occasions comme ça donc on voit le
cercueil là qui est remis sur le porte
canon il va maintenant traverser à
nouveau le centre de londres pour
permettre plus de gens possible de lui
faire leurs adieux le cortège va passer
en fait devant tous les endroits
mythiques de londres angleterre white
rôles au grand mall c'est la célèbre
artère là qui mène à buckingham va
passer une dernière fois à côté du
palais jusqu'à l'arc de wellington a
right par colin mais là il sera chargé
sur un corbillard et transporté à une
quarantaine de kilomètres au château de
windsor donc marque une cérémonie
bénéfices même si qu'accumuler que je
voudrais ce qui était dit tout à l'heure
parce que dans ce cadre oui l'église
catholique était réservé un cardinal
catholique qui a parlé puis avaient
toutes les affaires un certain nombre de
deouis de tradition protestante qui
étaient représentés les ils ont été
choisi par la reine elle-même avec john
tate web mais ce sont des chants et qui
ont été chantées à son mariage et à son
couronnement à une affection
particulière pour ça même ce sont des
hymnes britannique connue que vous dire
de cette cérémonie c'est que on y avait
l'alliance de l'église bien sûr de la
royauté et de la politique parce que
certains plans de caméra aller chercher
les têtes couronnées bien sûr mais les
anciens premiers ministres du canada de
grande-bretagne et usera la politique
était présente c'est une cérémonie
grandiose
fastueuse et points à tous était
millimétré au quart de tour ça c est me
l'a dit souvent il se sent préparé
depuis des années elle même avait
d'ailleurs aidé à planifier ses
funérailles
et comme la caméra les caméras d'année
en année se sont perfectionnés pour 1
eur voire vu plusieurs vous avez comme
correspondante suivi celle de diana à
l'abbaye de westminster également mais
là c'est encore plus beau les images
sont absolument extraordinaires sur ce
plan là c'est inouï vraiment inouïe sont
des images inoubliables une chose on en
parlait entre nous pendant qu'on
regardait ça peu d'émotion
personne que le vrai là et les gens là
c'est le roi charles iii un peu affecté
quand même les yeux
mais mais personne n'était vous savez
vraiment en peine lors on ne sentait
personnes affligées puis 10 il n'y avait
pas de larmes mais on n'était plus dans
la contemplation que dans la tristesse
personnel il y avait plus de gens qui
pleuraient dans les files d'attentes en
fin de semaine il faudrait voir pourquoi
d'ailleurs les gens disaient oui j'avais
un attachement il y avait des
psychologues pour unité les expliquer ça
pourquoi ces gens se réunissaient puis
voulait attendre des heures et des
heures pour se pourvoir le simplement
quelques secondes voire le cercueil
c'est le désir de se réunir bien sûr
mais aussi de 10 mais ma grand mère les
mais alors ma mère aussi alors je vois
aller manifester toujours été là on l'a
toujours connue elle a été là dans we
know grand moment il est jean interview
est certaine un truc leur est pas cette
cathédrale c'était c'était un peu plus
distant c'était plus solennelle beaucoup
de dignitaires beaucoup de têtes
couronnées qu'on a aperçu un petit peu
oui aperçu mais évidemment les la
famille royale britannique
c'est dans l'heure de montrer leur
chagrin c'est extrêmement seul on les
sentait très émue on a vu
quelques uns dont le prince édouard se
moucher bon pour vraiment essayé le
2-2 de changer son atmosphère mais il
reste que dans ce type d'événement l'eau
la famille royale
elle est émue on sent une dignité pour
fouad mes très respectueuses et la même
chose pour les têtes couronnées qui ont
participé comme vous avez dit on les a à
peine aperçu mais bon il est vert de
monaco le roi des pays-bas la reine le
roi philippe des belges de norvège et
margaret de danemark la dernière roue
irait il y avait aussi la princesse
margaret de roumanie le roi siméon ii
bulgarie alors le grand duc du
luxembourg
alors ils étaient ils étaient là pour
justement on aurait eu ce train qui ont
été si présent avec le roi olav pardon
le roi harald de norvège étaient aussi
il y parlera d'espagne aux dépens du roi
d'espagne la voix et mérite y était
aussi alors la famille et on a vu aussi
très brièvement les les dames d'honneur
les pages de la reine qui eux étaient
très très proches étaient avec elle même
pendant la pandémie ils ont été très
près c'est tout ce qu'ils ont on voit
les gens quatre chevaux de la
gendarmerie royale donc
des faits il dirige cette procession
elle avait la reine avait voulu un que
des représentants des pays dits désarmés
ou des pays du commonwealth soit
présenté à cette crb elle avait un
attachement tout particulier pour la
gendarmerie royale d'ailleurs un des
chevaux qu'elle a utilisée pour le trop
plein de couleurs pendant de nombreuses
années permise était un cadeau de la
gendarmerie royale donc que c'est chaud
mousser cuillé soit là c'est à cet
important pour elle d'avoir un
représentant elle assistait d'ailleurs
où est ce qu'on appelle et carrousel de
la grc je me souviens avoir couvert pour
et redit à dans le coin d'ottawa
longue cérémonie de carousel la haine et
elle a posé des questions sur les routes
s'intéressait apparaît une époque mais
l'avait trouvé quelqu'un qui parlait aux
choux littéralement quelqu'un qui avait
cette capacité de faire réagir les
chevaux elle avait engagé pour elle
alors à cause de cette dimension
équestre elle portait un grand intérêt
aux activités d'un jour sans grande
passion
et elle a vécu cette passion un peu de
façon parallèle elle avait son rôle de
chef d'état mais elle pouvait quand même
avoir s'agit réellement viser la montée
son cheval a bon dos jusque il ya
peut-être une année et elle était
évidemment c'était pas de l'improbable
mai et en avril dernier lorsqu'elle a
célébré son 96e anniversaire la photo
qui a été
publiée elle est encore avec de
magnifiques chevaux blancs donc on voit
cette ce cortège dont qui remonte
- la grande allée vers le palais de
buckingham et qui va comme ça a marché
jusqu'à l'arc de wellington arabe par
koné est là comme je vous disais il sera
chargé dans un corbillard et sera
conduit à windsor donc à 35 km de la
capitale et se mue long des routes on le
voit pas encore mais il ya énormément de
gens qui se sont massés pour pouvoir
rendre un dernier hommage à la reine et
on parlait de cet attachement mais c'est
quand même quelque chose
d'impressionnant d'avoir révérend
d'avoir vu tous ces gens faire la queue
à l'est qui tenait à les rendre un
dernier hommage à la reine dans un dans
une discipline dans un calme dans un
atmosphère très bon enfant aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être un petit peu plus sombre
parce que c'est la dernière fois bien
sûr oui mais là je vais te déjà que la
musique est un peu plus de plus
un
peu moins triste on sent déjà qu'un
mouvement peut-être mais c'est sûr que
les anglais m
dommage mais était très attaché à la
très attaché à la reine et que c'est
important pour eux aussi de la partie de
ces grandes ans d'histoire c'est cette
chose dont ils vont parler à leurs
petits enfants le jour où j'étais aux
funérailles de la reine c'était chose
qui se transmettent de famille en
famille et je les suis déçu on a entendu
pendant le sermon de l'archevêque encore
une fois que il avait elle a vu la reine
avait utilisé dans son adresse au moment
du coup vite cette chanson de vérone in
blue will meet again c'est une chanson
qui date de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et sellette l'angleterre est toujours
très attaché ces images de la guerre de
l'après-guerre qui ont été très très dur
et très très dur en particulier pour les
populations
plaisir populaire qui occupent qui en
ont bavé si on peut dire parce que le
rationnement a continué bien après les
autres pays européens et donc qui a
marqué et la reine est la voix yeux de
la monarchie à konaté attention d'être
très présent mais là trop sa part
la volontaire voilà donc c'est toujours
cesser la avec les générations qui vous
viennent qui pourront peut-être qu'ils
ont maintenant moins de moins de
contacts avec le 20e siècle la deuxième
guerre mondiale la plupart des vétérans
maintenant sont décédés ou sur le point
de céder c'est sûr que avec les années
qui passent en allemagne deux mois de
contacts directs donc ça change ça va
changer la connexion avec la monarchie
avec les grands les corps au moment du
monde est 20e ce processus certains ont
écrit que le xxème siècle commence 21e
commence maintenant pour les
britanniques or 2022 c'est à dire qu'ils
ont un changement de premier ministre
une certaine situation floue sur le plan
politique situation économique très très
dur actuellement l'inflation frappe plus
fort en grande bretagne qu'ailleurs
akela l'énergie aussi oui voilà c'est
très mal oui et la perte d'elizabeth
deux lots une transition vers on sait
trop quoi on ne sait pas ce qui va
donner le règne de charles haas et
beaucoup de transition et il se lance là
dans une espèce de fuite en avant on ne
parle pas de tout ça c'est ainsi on
parle de la reine une espèce de fuite en
avant on marque cet anniversaire marque
la fin de son règne mais après on s'est
réveillé la poésie au qu'est ce qu'on
fait dès demain matin en fait parce que
jusqu'à ce jusqu'à ce soir de la grande
bretagne bien sûr cet après-midi pour
nous ce sera l'hommage à la reine
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit conduite à son
dernier sa dernière demeure à windsor et
à partir de demain ben les choses vont
commencer à changer ou pas avec avec
charles iii non oui mais le deuil
familial lui va se poursuivre pour une
autre semaine alors seulement vraiment
deuil national géré le tie le deuil
national se termine aujourd'hui mais le
deuil de la famille vie va se poursuivre
sept jours un quart et ensuite les
activités vont reprendre d'une façon
habituelle mais on va quand même voir
lorsque leurs voix les prisons faire des
activités officielles ils vont encore
porter des complets sont sombres une
cravate quand c'est ça va prendre encore
peut-être deux ou trois semaines avant
que l'eau les couleurs reviennent pour
les activités courantes de la famille
donc la famille va pouvoir vivre son
deuil de façon un peu plus intime parce
que jusqu'à présent ça a été quand même
très très public avec très exigeant pour
eux mêmes aujourd'hui pour le pour
toutes ses enfants et ses petits-enfants
mais c'est très difficile de vivre un
deuil devant les caméras c'est sûr c'est
sûr que tout le monde nous gâte où
chaque chaque mouvement chaque geste
chaque chaque petite lame s'il y en a
c'est ses analyses et donc ils doivent
aussi se protéger en essayant ne veut
pas montrer ce que ce qu'ils pensent ça
fait partie du rôle et comment est-ce
que ça se passe derrière les portes des
différents paliers on ne sait pas trop
et c'est ce qui aussi a toujours des
problèmes familiaux qui sont encore en
train d'être besoin d'être résolue si on
peut dire mais tous se sont rassemblés
pour
pour la patriarche la matriarche
le départ de l'anah triarc et et c'est
ça qu'est ce qui va se passer à partir
de demain on ne sait pas trop la
nouvelle première ministre va devoir
trouver ces coudées franches par cas
réalité les dans un équilibre fragile
elle ne pâtit élu premier ministre a été
désigné premier ministre sa légitimité
vont être contestées rapidement et puis
il ya cette situation économique à
résoudre il ya tout ça je expliciter ce
que je disais tout à l'heure quand on
parlait de cérémonie où il ya peu
d'émotion vous aviez été témoin de des
funérailles de diana john qui avait
chanté il y avait des débordements de
l'arbre et c'était c'était une autre
ambiance c'était moins officiel que ce
l'était aujourd'hui il y avait quelque
chose de plus populaires dans cette
cérémonie il y avait un deuil qui était
exprimé aujourd'hui c'est plus bas vous
voilà c'est funérailles d'état on voit
disparaître une grande souveraine folle
manifesté il ya des deuils privés qui
vont s'exprimer mais
la page va quand même être tournée on va
surveiller charles on retombe dans la
réalité qu réponse à votre question on
retombe dans la réalité dès demain dès
demain et évidemment le tout le pays a
été en suspens depuis 11 jours
maintenant et là les activités vont
reprendre certains disaient mais oui on
est en pleine crise économique et tout
s'arrête pendant pendant 11 jours c'est
un peu difficile aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
c'est une journée fériée les écoles sont
fermées les commerces sont fermés donc
pour beaucoup de gens qui souffrent il
va falloir quand même que les attentes
des gestes de leur gouvernement et pour
charles iii il arrive donc dans une
période extrêmement difficile pour pour
la grande bretagne mais en même temps
peut-être que
cette période extrêmement difficile vont
lui apporter ce qu'il faut pour ma
mettre sa marque sur son régne albi
parce que bon et il a bien dit qu'il
voulait poursuivre
ce que sa mère a fait de servir le pays
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie donc c'est peut
être aussi l'occasion pour lui de
vraiment montrer
jusqu'où il peut aller pour aider
évidemment il pourra pas émettre
d'opinion le vraiment
définitif sur de n'importe quel sujet
mais il faut qu'ils gardent une certaine
réserve ce qu'il n'avait pas l'habitude
de faire il reste ils ont besoin ils
vont pouvoir avec le premier la première
mini ce justement de discuter des points
chauds et
fatah est justement faire sa marque de
cette façon la bd par des discussions
très productive a amené à trouver des
solutions il y trouvait des rapidement
puis du point d'eau brocard même on ne
revit chaque scène où il signe des
documents puis là il se met à un cercle
au but met en fureur il est très aisé
rites et alors il faut le dégager de là
vous avez vu il faut l'enlever de la
place et là c'est camilla qui vient
sauver la situation et qui à sa place
c'est une des documents on sort la pièce
littéralement et via une autre occasion
aussi ou site impatienté à l'égard de la
question s'il y en a beaucoup vu ça sent
les réseaux sociaux aux amis et aux
mâles sont irritation du musicien et
fait mieux côté capricieux on peut bâtir
diva qui apparaît et dont ils vont être
devoir se débarrasser parce que y toutes
ces histoires comme qu'on lui mettait sa
pâte à dents sur son dentifrice veut
dire ce faux s'impose sur sa brosse à
dents le prince capricieux il devra se
débarrasser de cette image est soit dit
en passant on entendu camilla
pour notre part comme canadiens ou
québécois
c'était la première fois qu'on entendait
sa voix les britanniques étaient hommage
à la reine
elle a parlé dans sa gueule bleus
n'oubliez pas mais on voit personne très
grave
et très très calme très haut maîtrise
d'elle-même
plusieurs disent que c'est elle qui va
qualifier qui va apporter
justement on l'a vu justement dans le la
scène des des plumes peut-être pas là
lors de la programmation mais lorsqu'il
a été belle face parce que la plume
coulé sur ses doigts il avait deux
langues sur les doigts et vraiment c'est
elle qui s'est approchée qui lui a parlé
et qui est vraiment je crois que son
rôle à elle veut être aussi ça de
l'aider à
résister sur d'humeur mais évidemment
faut dire aussi c'était toute l'émotion
de ce qu'il faisait qui a peut-être fait
que perdre un peu patience avec eux mais
il a quand même vu déjà changer un petit
peu la façon de faire parce qu'il est
allé vers les gens dans des prix dit ban
fully là mais son fils il fallait se
rapprocher oui je pense qu'il a été très
bien conseillé au début c'est sûr
c'est sûr que lehman foule
un visage
personnel il a même embrassé des gens
c'est comme c'est quand même pas évident
normalement on ne touche pas les
monarques donc ça c'est ça c'était
vraiment un grand changement au
protocole d'embrasser ses femmes a été
beau qu'on avait vu la semaine dernière
c'était très très étonnant et donc qu'il
veut vraiment en tout cas on encourage à
travailler à son profil public pour qu'
il puisse établir des atomes crochus si
on peut dire avec avec les gens qui
dépassent un peu cette figure très
austère très capricieuse que les gens
connaissent certainement et dont on ne
connaît pas finalement grand chose parce
qu'il a été aussi l'humilité peut-être
qui s'est exprimé beaucoup sur cet
aspect on en attend de voir s'il va
pouvoir voir de l' influence au niveau
des changements climatiques par exemple
ça va être la grande question mais pour
le reste c'est quand même un businessman
très avisé c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
des deals avec des princes de moyen
orient etc qui sont plus du tout sûr
qu'il ya des choses un peu compliquées
et donc est ce qu'il va pouvoir vraiment
devenir une personne sympathique comme
la reine la reine elizabeth c'est une
grande question et c'est ce qu'il arrive
pas tout jeune donc déjà il est un peu
je veux dire enfreignez physique
physiquement il est pas forcément
mais
la ville a attendu ce moment
toute sa vie pour ça maintenant donc
c'est ça aussi on peut imaginer des
irritations aimé le style ne marchait
pas j'ai attendu toute ma vie le stylo
doit marcher
les work out dont vous parliez et l
extraordinaire de sapin il s'approchait
de la fouille était chaleureux ils ont
tous fait des waka bac j'ai vu le prince
william qui en est fait même sophie
restions qui la contestent de wessex si
je ne m'abuse
elle faisait les waka basse avec grande
efficacité avec son mari le prince
attendait c'est à toi voilà c'est ça il
faisait du guacamole et tous deux
étaient extrêmement efficace chaleureux
avec les gens et discute même charles
j'ai vu charles pas trop mal qui parle
avec les gens
lui même été voir voir les gens qui
faisait la queue et qu'ils attendaient
pour les encourager pour les remercier
les deux fils les deux princes aussi ont
été vus ensemble williams en train de
parler aux gens et de lire tous ces
messages les gens venaient des pc
noceurs c'est un petit signe de deuil
des près si elle change ment quand même
oui de changement mais aussi de montrer
que ils apprécient ce que les gens font
pour leurs familles d'enfants parce que
bon il y aurait pu rester encore quatre
murs et attendre le matin des
funérailles et la dalle et parce que
chacun a été dans différentes villes de
de l'angleterre du royaume uni et de
s'approcher des gens c'est vraiment de
vouloir partager un peu le deuil du
peuple vit avec eux et c'est ça que
c'est ce genre de
d'attachement qu'il crée entre la
famille royale est là
le peuple britannique et c'est fort
apprécié ça c'est certain qu'on voit
c'est nier ces centaines de milliers de
personnes dans les rues qui sont massés
donc pour lui rendre hommage qui suivent
le cortège et on vend rejoint de marc
isabelle rochon parce que on peut dire
que la sécurité marc isabelle ce qui est
déployé pour cette journée bah c'est
énorme c'est aussi exceptionnelle ouais
la sécurité qui déployait qui est encore
plus plus importante que ce qu'on a vu
aux olympiques en 2012 notamment parce
qu'il ya des dirigeants de partout à
travers le monde qui sont venus qui sont
rassemblés au même endroit on parle d'au
moins dix mille policiers au moins deux
mille militaires et aux pans de 36
kilomètres de barrières qui ont été
mises en place pour la foule parce qu'on
attendait beaucoup plus de gens qu'on
mariage de arie de meghan markle en 2018
il ya des drones aussi qu'ils ont été
mis en place pour surveiller la foule en
hauteur des rues qui ont été barrées une
vingtaine de rues ont été barrées il ya
un espace aussi de restrictions
aériennes qui a été mis en place à
londres alors beaucoup de sécurité il ya
quand même une certaine est ainsi dans
la dernière semaine ici ce qu'on voit
c'est un homme qui criait lors du
passage du dudu
c'est donc oui à edimbourg il a été
appréhendé par les policiers il a écrit
des mots donc au prince andrew on a vu
d'autres incidents aussi donc cette
femme qui tenait c'est ce papier on note
mike king dont des personnes qui sont
contre la monarchie et elle a été
arrêtée et au lendemain de cet incident
d'un des gens qui ont manifesté contre
la monarchie de manière pacifique non
pour montrer qu'ils étaient contre ces
arrestations
un autre incident survenu vendredi je me
montre ici ça s'est passé très
rapidement un homme qui a voulu aller
toucher le cercueil de la reine et qui
rapidement a été plaqué au sol par les
forces de l'ordre les gens qui étaient
présents la sécurité qui était présente
alors tous ces exemples vous montrer à
quel point la sécurité est prête à
réagir et ce très rapidement oui quand
même des réactions à tout ça parce que
les gens ont dit on a le droit de
manifester pacifiquement et montrer
notre désaccord avec la monarchie mais
jusqu'à présent quand même ça se déroule
relativement bien tout ça quand on pense
il y avait sept cent cinquante mille
personnes qui ont fait la queue qui ont
attendu dans les rues de londres pendant
des heures et des heures c'était quand
même
impressionnant de voir à quel point tout
ça se déroulait dans le calme merci
beaucoup
on va aller maintenant voir notre notre
ami raphaël bouvier auclair qui est
toujours à hyde park où la cérémonie
était diffusée sur grand écran et
raphaël quelle était l'atmosphère dans
quel état d'esprit était les gens autour
de vous pendant cette cérémonie
les gens étaient très très attentif la
foule a considérablement augmenté depuis
la dernière fois à laquelle on s'est
parlé c'est l'un de ces difficile
d'estimer le nombre de personnes qui
avaient on connaîtra les chiffres
éventuellement mais il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de journées raciste et donc à
ses funérailles d'état diffusé sur
vraiment plusieurs écrans à travers
eyebox grand parc londonien autour de
moi hier cet écran d'ailleurs on diffuse
toujours la prochaine étape c'est à dire
la procession funéraire donc qui se
déroule dans les rues de londres et les
gens étaient très silencieux étaient
venus en famille d'un peu partout
d'ailleurs au royaume uni un pas
uniquement de la honte évidemment il ya
des gens qui est de la grande région
londonienne et on a parlé à des membres
du public qui venaient d'aussi loin que
newcastle dans le nord-est l'anglais
alors on l'a de petits problèmes de
communication pouvez vous imaginer mais
tous les gens qui sont là tous les
médias aussi qui diffuse à partir du
centre-ville de londres c'est
extrêmement difficiles les
communications sont extrêmement
difficile mais tous ces gens autour de
raphaël maintenant vont se sont déplacés
ont commencé à se déplacer pour essayer
d'apercevoir ou de voir cette procession
funéraire qui se poursuit donc vers
l'arc de wellington à ce moment-là tout
ça se fait à pied jusqu'à la rue
wellington à partir de ce moment là le
cercueil sera miss dans un corbillard
pour être transporté jusqu'à
donc c'est une quarantaine de kilomètres
mais ça va prendre quand même pas mal de
temps parce qu'on va rouler lentement
pour permettre aux gens
de voir les cambodgiens de voir le
cortège et comme on l'a vu lorsque le le
corbier à se déplacer entre
le château de balmoral et edimbourg un
nouveau 280 que l'ama est ok plus de six
heures donc
ça va être la même
la même procédure on va rouler lentement
pour permettre aux gens de voir une
dernière fois le cercueil de la reine
elizabeth on va juste écouter quelques
instants un peu cette cortège et la
musique
[Musique]
voilà pour ce cortèges qui se dirigent
toujours vers l'arc de wellington
encore quelques minutes de ce cortège
dont qui est suivi par la famille royale
et
qui on a vu tout à l'heure ce cercueil
donc tiré par 142 marin on peut
s'étonner mais que nous avait expliqué
donc c'est une tradition qui date de
l'époque de la reine vite et rieur et on
a vu aussi le des membres de la de la
maison de la reine l'on nous voyons les
cavaliers de la demande de la
de la cavalerie de la maison du roy
d'onglets les live gold et
de base ce sont des membres de la
famille des irish guards
qui sont suivis par un groupe qui porte
un tabac avec l'étendard qui représente
l'étendard de la famille royale
[Musique]
l'action pour les jeunes qui viennent de
se joindre à vous l'agression du fus de
canon la reine victoria c'est à commande
suffit des rails en été en février 1911
et là il faisait un froid de canard et
chevaux compris panique et sur conseil
d'un membre de maison royale le futur
edouard 7 il n'était pas encore cours à
nice était le fils d victoria il a
adopté cette décision il a écrit il à
gré cette formule qui ne fait retirer de
ses recueils pas redémarré en pleine
forme c'était la seule façon parce que
les chevaux voulait plus se serait mal
passée allons avec l'affût de canon on a
transporté le cercueil c'est un immense
succès alors on a gardé ça ça a été la
même chose pour churchill et il faut
aussi signaler ce lien particulier qu'a
la famille royale avec ceux qui hélas
seigneur force des armes marine la
marine le duc d'edimbourg ayant servi
il n'a pas charles oui ils ont fait leur
service et oui c'est ça qui porte la
majorité d'entre eux aujourd'hui je
crois que chez les hauts placés là de la
famille wade parte uniforme de la marine
aujourd'hui une fois tous ces militaires
donc au garde à vous qu'il faut une haie
d'honneur pour le cercueil de la reine
on me dit que raphaël est de retour on
l'a retrouvée on a pu refaire notre
connexion alors raphaël parlez-nous de
l'atmosphère un peu autour de vous on
entend les coups de canon on entendait
de bigben aussi tout à l'heure ce sont
un peu diffus l'camp chaque minute là
oui on vient tout juste de l'entendre
même si on est assez loin effectivement
je vous disais c'est même tout à l'heure
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
se sont présentés ce qui explique nos
problèmes de communication aussi donc
beaucoup de personnes qui se sont
présentées à hyde park parce
qu'évidemment le centre de la capitale
c'était difficile d'accès aujourd'hui
aux abords de l'abbaye de westminster
et aux abords du palais de buckingham
donc ici avant un espace qui était
offert aux gens pour venir regarder sur
des écrans géants ces cérémonies
beaucoup beaucoup de calme je vous dirai
dans la foule les gens étaient très
attentifs à cette cérémonie à ses
funérailles d'état qui ont été présentés
un des moments importants évidemment et
on en a parlé avec les gens qui sont
dans la foule à presque deux minutes de
silence qui a été respectée à la toute
fin de la cérémonie et ail par ici qui
pourtant un très grand parc où il y
avait beaucoup de gens des billets de
milliers de personnes on n'entendait
rien du tout ça vraiment été très bien
respectée par des gens qui voulaient
venir ici vers la capitale plutôt que de
regarder ces cérémonies à la maison pour
marquer un moment d'histoire parce que
c'est effectivement ce que ces atouts
les toutes les personnes à qui on a
parlé non connus qui vise à besse 2
comme monarque à la tête du royaume uni
5 une période de changement qui va
évidemment s'opérer à la tête du pays
mais là on voulait vraiment dire au
revoir à cette souveraine voici une
femme à qui on a parlé tout de suite
après la série
[Musique]
je respecte
oui la fin d'une époque c'est le
sentiment qu'ont beaucoup de gens et qui
maintenant se sont déplacées je crois et
qui essaye de voir la procession
funéraire oui
oui exactement il ya eu un mouvement de
foule en fait dès la fin de la cérémonie
dès que le circuit la reine elizabeth a
quitté l'abbaye de wesminster donc les
gens ont commencé à se déplacer parce
que cette procession funèbre et elle se
terminera non loin de notre parc à
l'arche de wellington donc c'est tout
proche d'ici donc les gens commencent à
marcher en espérant peut-être pouvoir
apercevoir quelques moments de cette
cérémonie ce qui sera pas évident je
vous dirais céline parce qu'il avait
déjà beaucoup beaucoup de londoniens de
britanniques de touristes aussi qui
s'étaient déjà massés le long des
avenues sur laquelle sur lesquels vont
circuler donc les véhicules qui
participent à cette procession et le
cercueil de la reine elizabeth donc il
ya des gens qui vont tenter d'y aller
parce qu'ils se disent on est à londres
justement c'est un moment d'histoire on
va tenter d'en voir le plus possible il
ya aussi des gens qui vont vaquer à
leurs occupations parce qu'après tout
c'est une journée qui a été déclaré jour
férié ici au royaume uni commerces qui
sont fermées donc les gens par exemple
sont venus ici en famille partager un
repas bas vont rester profiter du parc
ou encore rentrés à la maison et puis on
sait qu'à partir de demain et bien la
vie va me prendre la vie va continuer on
en parlait tout à l'heure le pays est un
peu sur pause depuis la mort de la reine
ya toutes sortes de débats compte
desquels on a moins entendu parler sur
toute la question de l'inflation des
prix de l'énergie va nous ça va
reprendre mais aujourd'hui on voulait
profiter entre les gens qui étaient ici
en grand nombre voulait profiter de ce
moment pour justement marqué la fin de
ce chapitre de 70 ans de l'histoire du
royaume oui la fin d'un chapitre merci
raphaël on voyait tout à l'heure les
images de la reine consort de la
princesse de galles en voiture dont qui
suivent le corner il leur en voiture
avec
2 le prince george et la princesse
charlotte aussi en voiture dont qui
suivent tous à 9 ans 7 ans quand même
jeunes pour ses enfants et
c'est un même temps un apprentissage
qu'ils font pour ce que va être leur vie
dans l'est dans le futur parce que
surtout pour le prince george c c'est un
jour ça sera son tour d'être roi et ça
je crois que ça va vraiment
encore plus souffert pour lui faire
prendre conscience du rôle qui leur a
joué dans un futur évidemment qu'on ne
connaît pas mais qui peut être fait dans
une trentaine d'années alors
c'est quand même exceptionnel pour ces
enfants là de participer à ce à cet
événement vous voyez d'ailleurs leur
jubilé les deux enfants du prince
william qui était très agitée dans une
loge quelque part il fallait que
quelqu'un d'autonome belle princesse les
calmes et leur petit sa maison elle
avait pris avait été donnée la vedette
là le plus jeune
qui avec il trouvait que les avions
faisaient trop de bruit qui faisait des
grimaces mais je vous dirai à 4 un
enfant c'est difficile de le contrôler
pendant qu'il reste quand pendant 3-4 a
minima b si difficile donc je ne
finirais aussi j'en ai fait l'expérience
dernièrement de contenir des enfants et
un mois qu'ils soient déjà très très
indisciplinés mais s'il y en a qui
doivent l'être c'est bien issu de la
famille royale or c'est pas évident de
les amener l'eau mais comme vous dites
j'étais en apprentissage c'est un art et
puis c'est un apprentissage c'est aussi
un symbole pour la population
britannique qui souvent qui souvent a
peur de donner des enfants par exemple à
des funérailles et c'est très très
important de pouvoir dire au revoir à la
personne qu'on a perdu c'est un moment
psychologique c'est un moment spirituel
mais c'est un moment cathartique aussi
parce que c'est là qu'on se rend compte
la personne n'est dans ce cercueil c'est
la fin est ce assez haut niveau au
niveau de formation personnelle si c'est
très important donc neuf de voir ses
deux enfants ça va peut-être encouragé
les parents aussi à à
encourager leurs enfants à venir parce
que souvent quand j'étais prêtre en
angleterre c'est souvent on avait le
problème on veut emmener james parce que
c'est trop jeune mais si jamais trop
jeune pour dire au revoir et apprécié
des choses qu'on peut regretter pour
toujours c'est sûr que c'est un contexte
différent aussi et on revoit passé les
images de william et harry quand il
était tout petit derrière le cercueil de
leurs nerfs beaucoup de parallèles aussi
encore une fois et donc ça va jouer sur
les émotions pour les gens de voir les
petits c'est des petits enfants cette
fois ci mais quand même ça ça ça mais ça
dans un contexte très familial qui va
toucher ce faut souligner c'est que le
principal est pas facile
la cérémonie
les funérailles d'état son passé et
elles se sont déroulées sans anicroche
il n'y avait pas rien qui dépasse
c'était millimétré comme je disais tout
à l'heure et tout a bien fonctionné là
il y aurait pu y avoir des dérapages
rien rien rien d'un prévu alors la
maison royale de fleurs qu'on dit doit
être très contente de tout ça il reste
encore évidemment windsor il reste le
cortège mais on peut dire que si on veut
faire une bilal que la reine veut tout
bien orchestré et les verts castrés son
départ elle n'a pas raté sa sortie comme
on disait autrefois certes on peut se
réjouir et tout à tout a bien fonctionné
cette cérémonie mais aussi tout ce qui
se passe depuis son décès la semaine
dernière tout si ces visites tout ça
s'est
très bien passé il ya eu quelques petits
incidents mais avec la foule qui avait
les gens qui s'étaient déplacés mais les
gens extraordinaires mais les les
britanniques justement ce que
pendant ces dix journées ils ont écarté
leur
leur mésentente ou lors
leurs craintes sur la situation qu'ils
vivent présentement pour vraiment pour
eux la famille royale c'est vraiment
leur famille on le sent maintenant tout
ce que je vois qu'on en parle de
botanique faire un commentaire ce sens
et on veut lui rends hommage parce que
c'est un peu une partie de nous et elle
elle fait partie de nous alors on veut
on veut vraiment montrer mais pas à elle
elle est partie mais à sa famille on a
un attachement on a eu un attachement
pendant toutes ces années à la sirène et
le sentiment est vraiment présent alors
il à la foule on voyait des jeunes des
vieux
les a toutes les enquêtes de toutes les
classes sociales également on croyait
que ce serait une ide générationnel
comme quand les gens vont à l'église
aujourd'hui pardonnez moi on voit
surtout dit dans des églises
a fait mais mais non là c'est un moment
tous les multi générationnelle et les
jeunes étaient émus ou six as et j'en ai
vu qui pleurait
été surpris parce qu'ils n'ont pas
surpris parce qu est ce qui a
certainement des familles c'est une
qu'il ya une grande tradition de
participation aux événements
internationaux mais aussi de passivation
pas l'armée par les forcés mais pas tout
le côté civique tout tout tout tout dans
la vie britannique sont liés à la
monarchie dans tous les gens qui sont
plus ou moins impliqués ils ont une
familiarité avec la famille royale avec
la reine avec le faste qui va avec et ça
fait partie de ceux qui sont hors jeu
les végétariens aussi dans la city
s'étaient c'était partout
donc je suis pas étonné dans un certain
sens c'est sûr que avec les générations
ça va peut-être se perdre un peu et
c'est sûr que y avait une sympathie
particulière pour cette monarque le vt
sur le trône pendant plus de 70 ans ce
que moi un commentaire que je voulais
faire au niveau des liturgies sur un peu
dire depuis lundi dernier depuis
edimbourg c'est que en même temps on a
pensé beaucoup à la reine née dans le
contexte c'est du surge il y avait tout
un moment de préparation des prières de
préparation pour cette transition donc
vraiment
glisser dans les deux relais de ces
cérémonies de funérailles
un sous-texte 2 on se prépare ça y est
le roi arrive vive le roi et donc qui
permet aussi à la population mitani
peut-être de prendre ce sous texte de la
prégnance et d'être à partir de demain
prêt pour cette nouvelle réalité et je
pense qu'on n'a peut-être pas vraiment
pensé les étés c'était là à chaque étape
toutes ces grandes visites dans les
grandes capitales des quatre royaumes
des trois royaumes plus londres
maintenant mais
il ya toute une préparation toute ces
liturgies s'est fait avec beaucoup de
précision il s'est beaucoup de réflexion
derrière et c'est pas c'est pas anodin
on prépare on a préparé et ça y est on y
est a fait un dernier adieu et demain
ses chats
mais si charles et comme
c'est la faillite comme on disait c'est
on revient à une certaine réalité on va
être confronté un peu à toutes ces
difficultés qui qu'on a tenté d'oublier
depuis intérieur intérieur et extérieur
intérieur on a parlé de la situation
économique bien sûr la situation
politique par le parlement est instable
à leur sport et le corps manuel
les gens du commun doit être les
enregistrements passé hier sur bbc gens
qui rendait hommage à la reine mais
après certains d'entre eux voient
maintenant la royauté à travers le
prisme du colonialisme c'est à dire plus
que ça à l'esclavagisme ça va être un
peu plus difficile il avait deux temps
une grande diplomate elle avait su quand
l' empire s'est désagrégé le sauver en
quelque sorte de récupérer en faire mal
quand benoît sur d'autres bases et elle
a su rencontrer gardé des liens avec ces
gens là c'est ses fabuleuses qu'elle a
réussi sur ce plan d' y en a qui a
redonné beaucoup et ne sont à prendre
écrit veto en fin de semaine vous disait
que poutine par exemple qui veut
protéger ses coloniale s'est aussi
gardée l'ukraine a annoncé
qu'il y aurait des leçons à prendre
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait on sait
pas par la force en annexant tout
simplement le si vous voulez le voisin
proche c'est du colonialisme proche mais
la reine avait su qu'un des partis de
lempire se détachait gardé des liens
parler avec eux ça c'est une de ces
grandes réussites sur le plan politique
vide amant avec l'arrivée de charles vii
en suspens parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
pays qui se disent maintenant qu'ils
commencent à songer que peut-être il est
temps de mettre fin avec les monarchies
des mêmes et bien commun mais dans les
derniers mois
le roi charles le prince william ont
déjà
ont déjà dit que il voulait que ce
qu'est le commonwealth aujourd'hui soit
examinée
chante modifié pour le rendre encore
plus efficace alors ça va être une des
pires cas moi une des premières tâches
est laquelle le roi charles beau votre
travail et ils ont passé un mauvais
quart de dans l'île caraïbe à la veille
du
regarder cette cérémonie c'est que ce
cortège qui se poursuit en ce moment
toujours à travers les rues de lons là
on voit tous ces drapeaux cette haie
d'honneur des militaires c'est la
famille royale toujours et de vin de
marche dans la brosse et souvent les les
marins delà
de la marine on voit la page de la reine
elizabeth paul white blue et c'est avec
lui qu'elle est james bande ka le fait
le fameux clip lors des jeux olympiques
de 2012 donc il était
très très près lot 5 de la reine pendant
plus de plus de 40
alors ses funérailles de la reine
elizabeth on a une écho à différents
endroits au pays c'est le cas à halifax
en nouvelle écosse où se trouve l oic
rodriguez mais je commence à montréal
avec karine bastien alors karine ni un
rassemblement dans un pub anglais pour
suivre ces cérémonies
rassemblés depuis très tôt ce matin
depuis et 5 heures une quarantaine
cinquantaine de personnes ici et on va
parler justement avec l'instigateur de
cette idée d'avoir voulu rassembler les
gens pour les débats y est
co-propriétaire de burgundy laâyoune
donc dites moi pourquoi vous avez eu
cette idée d'être de faire un appel
justement montréalais de se rassembler
ici aujourd'hui mais comme on se parlait
en avance le la communité c'est
exactement qu'est ce que genève ne ment
comme ça serait présent
le pub c'est exactement le location en
angleterre où tout le monde se remette
ensemble au cas où celle endroit sûr
pour nous ce type avait pas de choix
comme le pub anglaise ici au moréas
avait 13 ans on savait que l'on avait là
public qui bull est un endroit pour se
rencontrer pas juste rester à leur
maison puis on a dit c'est ce qu'on va
faire sa cure dans la matin c'est c'est
une tombe c'est une connexion avec
l'angleterre ou si vous avez des
origines anglaises oui les origines
anglaises bien de mon dos mon grand mère
puis à
bien peu de connexions là bas aussi
quand je pense de qu'est ce qu'on
regarde maintenant pendant lé pa semaine
c'est la même chose du sang peu de
famille qui est la connaîtra pas il n'y
a pas de vraie connexion mais les
connexions anglais avec le famille
qu'elle représente pour vous la
famille
quelqu'un qui est hélas toujours
je pensais à plusieurs canadienne des
montréalaises n'importe qui si tu
demandes la question je pense la
question c'est que
on a perdu notre communication à
montréal aussi décidément c'est pas
facile aujourd'hui mais c'était
intéressant donc le preuve le
propriétaire de ce pub où les gens se
sont rassemblés pour regarder cette
cérémonie qui disait ben elle représente
pour moi la famille c'est ce que c'est
quand c'est ce qu'on se disait alors on
va aller voir héloïse qui a recueilli l
des témoignages à halifax alors et
eloïse qu'est ce qui en ressort là aussi
les gens voulaient se rassembler
ouais céline alors je vous précise
d'entrée de jeu ici c'est vraiment cet
après midi qu'il y aura une cérémonie
commémorative d'ailleurs à l'église
derrière moi il y aura une messe et ça
sera ouvert au public à 14 heures donc
premier arrivé premier servi et le
lieutenant gouverneur de la nouvelle
écosse le premier ministre rendront
hommage à la reine il y aura à la suite
de sa duo de la citadelle 21 coups de
canons pour rendre hommage à la reine
elizabeth ii mais déjà ce matin on s'est
promené dans les rues d'halifax des rues
beaucoup plus tranquille parce que vous
savez ici en nouvelle-écosse et un férié
aujourd'hui et on a rencontré plusieurs
personnes tout ce qu'ils avaient quelque
chose à dire par rapport à la reine et
on sent quand même cet attachement vous
savez ici en nouvelle écosse il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui sont d'origine
britannique alors on sentait surtout
cette émotion peut-être de la part des
personnes un peu plus âgé des
générations précédentes r on a rencontré
un homme qui lui quand il avait 8 ans a
assisté à la cérémonie de couronnement
de la reine dont il se souvient très
bien d'avoir vu ça ici dans un théâtre
d'halifax à la suite de ça d'avoir vu la
reine passé lorsqu'il était dans la
marine canadienne donc pour les
générations un peu plus âgés on a
entendu ces histoires là pour les jeunes
je voudrais que c'est des émotions un
peu plus partagés certains qui n'ont pas
cette main ce même attachement envers la
couronne britannique
mais on sentait quand même que dans tous
les cas c'est important pour eux d'avoir
cette journée fériée aujourd'hui pour
rendre hommage à la reine dont tous
m'ont dit oui c'est une bonne idée
d'avoir un férié d'avoir ce moment de
réflexion de revenir quand même sur le
règne d'elizabeth 2 qui a régné pendant
soixante dix ans donc je laisse entendre
quelques personnes qu'on ne rencontre
ici halifax
donc je vous le disais beaucoup plus de
gens à la maison aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'ils regardent justement ses
funérailles en direct dès cet après midi
il y aura cette cérémonie si l église
dont on sera sur place on s'attend à ce
qu'il y ait un peu plus de gens mais
quand même je vous le dirai ans s'est
rendu dans les dernières semaines devant
la résidence du lieutenant-gouverneur on
a vu des gens déposé des fleurs en
hommage à la reine des gens signer le
livre de condoléances donc on sent que
quand même pour eux c'est important de
faire cette transition avec le nouveau
roi est donc de montrer quand même
qu'ils étaient attachés à elizabeth 2
qui s'est rendu à halifax à saint ahon
nouvelle écosse à cinq reprises la
dernière fois en 2010 est vraiment des
milliers de personnes étaient sorties
dans la pluie battante céline pour
l'avoir donc on voyait que c'était
important pour eux à l'époque et encore
aujourd'hui très bien merci héloïse est
d'ailleurs une cérémonie commémorative
aura aussi lieu à ottawa un peu plus
tard aujourd'hui on vous la présentera
d'ailleurs en direct donc à l'église
croate juge d'ottawa
c'est l'événement fédéral si on
connaissait la houle et les personnes à
deux personnalités
18 de la vie civique que des dizaines du
canada sont rassemblées pour les
funérailles qui prennent due à la crue
la lacra la cathédrale anglicane
d'ottawa
beaucoup 2010 promet une journée sera
présent from - cours une cour
allocutions et puis ça va être assez
festif en même temps un ginette reno
sera la vitrine bright donc pas
seulement une cérémonie religieuse mais
ces cds événement qui rassemble le monde
ah c'est sûr que c'est sûr que
en plus dans chaque pays chacun y met
son message sa couleur locale si on peut
dire donc c'était important d'avoir les
personnalités locales un chef qui vont
chanter je sais pas s'ils vont chanter
pendant le service ils ont chanté je
peux donc donc peut-être à leyton jonah
dudit canal c'est eux qui vont réussir à
faire pleurer la fibre canadienne mais
c'est sûr que le chant le rassemblement
ça fait ça fait partie de la façon dont
on peut se souvenir des choses je
pensais ce défi les rails c'est souvent
le moment où les familles ne se voit pas
les gens qui nous qui ne se parlent plus
se rencontrent et là on voit peut-être
les chefs d'état du commonwealth qui se
retrouvent se faire partie participer à
des événements comme ça ça vous rappelle
les liens qui vous qui vous rallie
finalement et ça va peut-être les
encourager aussi à continuer les
discussions qu'il mène noir de la
famille l'emblème du cercueil qui passe
devant le palais de buckingham une
dernière fois pour la reine
la famille se réunit du commonwealth et
il comprend tout bien pour tous les
mêmes la même fibre démocratique
et puis elle demande aux autres chefs
d'état ou six qui sont ici qu'ils
partagent pas ces valeurs là mais qu'on
invite est quand même le le prince
héritier d'arabie saoudite et s'ils y
étaient vos funérailles il est à londres
alors l'yonne on rallie les familles
mais avec certaines réserves je sais pas
si vous avez pensé à un point c'est la
dernière reine pour un bout de temps
c'est la deuxième ère élisabéthaine
comme disait churchill qui vient de se
terminer mais pour les prochaines
générations ce seront des rois
william son fils la ligne de succession
direct c'est 3 à
l'époque des femmes à moins de données
prévues l'époque des femmes qui
détiennent la couronne c'est fini pour
un bon buteur god save the king c'est ce
qu'on veut c'est ça c'est ça qu'on va
entendre
voilà beaucoup de gens a quand même qui
se recueillent pour
dire adieu à leur reine donc comme je le
disais à la dernière pendant un certain
temps
il ya des héritières mais quand on
regarde la ligne et il ya des héritières
de manière latérale
mais les succès sont en première ligne
ce sont tous des hommes
you will i am et georges et ensuite
c'est la presse charles donc elle est en
3e position si on peut penser que
évidemment il faudrait qu'il ya une
catastrophe pour que
la précieuse charlotte way l'héritière
mais non il reste surtout maintenant que
on a changé la loi de la
décision parce que avant c'était tous
les hommes avant jeune femme mais
maintenant c'est vraiment depuis 2013
c'est parole des naissances donc c'est
pour ça que la princesse charlotte
nouveau perdu son sa place lorsque son
frère louis est née et elle est restée
troisième maintenant troisième dans
l'ordre de ses nombreux la princesse
anne llc fait jouer d'où
elle se ramasse l'on est dans la liste
étant dit que c'était trop actif oui
c'est ça parce que oui elle est née
avant que la loi change à la loi ne lui
donne pas une espèce que prix monte elle
ne donne plus tôt aux autres femmes plus
jeunes dans la famille elle elle est la
grande perdante de sur ce remaniement
même sur la table c'est ce royal l'a
beaucoup vu au cours des derniers jours
elle a été très présente l accompagner
des poules de sa mère en écosse et de la
ramener elle va jouer un rôle important
elle va continuer à assumer des
fonctions officielles
depuis plusieurs années c'est elle qui
en fait le plus à chaque année c'est
toujours autour de 700 750 activités
officielles par année qu'elle accomplit
c'est quand même quelques que 71 ans
mais il reste qu'elle va être encore
très présente comme les comptes de son
sexe vont aider le nouveau roi
accomplir d'autres tâches officielle
parce que l'eau est évidemment le fait
que le prince un duo et les comptes les
ducs de ce sex ne participe plus à
aucune activité officielle alors c'est
ce qu'ils ont pu suivre les condos beau
sexe et la princesse anne qui va
entreprendre continuer les activités
évidemment dans une dizaine d'années le
prêt ce genre je vais commencer en enfer
dans dix ans il aura 19 ans donc il va
être il va déjà avoir commencé à faire
des activités officielles mais pour les
sept huit prochaines années j'ai bien
l'impression que le nouveau roi va
compter sur son frère et sa soeur oui et
un circuit un double et
imaginables de l'ifer des bêtes faut
insérer des messes et ça situe vraiment
trop risqué mais encore une fois la
comtesse de wessex sophie se
débrouillait très bien là dedans on dit
que c'est une grande diplomates ou six
entre les membres de la famille c'est
une conciliatrice elle pourrait être
appliqué aussi à jouer un rôle plus
actif parce que c'était une des plus
effacé des princesses mais moins
maintenant mais ça sera un des défis du
nouveau roi de gérer la famille royale
parce que on dit qu'un jour voudrait
bien pouvoir revenir reprendre un peu de
services et mais il va falloir le garder
un distance après évidemment toutes ces
allégations
d'agression sexuelle je crois bien
régler à coups de millions de da et ses
activités officielles temps qu'a passé
s'est terminé comme ceux du
le duc de so sexy c'est en ça très bien
même dans cette dans cette série
banlieue c'est seulement ont leur permis
une fois de porter l'uniforme pour une
activité bien précise mais encore ce
matin ils étaient ils n'étaient pas en
uniforme et un en civil ce que les
messieurs l'opinion publique je pense le
plus le ne permettrait pas non les
journaux ne le supporterais pas et je
pense que charles va certainement aussi
va suivre les conseils qu'on va lui
donner parce qu'il a peut-être une des
velléités différente de sa mère c'est
une chose mais il va falloir aussi que
peut-être qui se soutiennent nasa des
nouvelles réalités même si même s'il
avait peut-être plus plus d'ouverture
sur une rédemption s'opposer à cela mais
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas c'est
sûr que l'opinion publique lines ou
parler des personnages comme guide des
chefs d'état ou des dignitaires un peu
plus controversé mais quand même sur la
liste y avait quelques pays qui
n'étaient pas invités on a parlé de
l'avenir poutine mais il y avait la
police tant la syrie la birmanie
la corée du nord oui mais vous parler de
dictature
à l'envers des parieurs du commonwealth
serait une contradiction totale que de
les inviter mais bin salman quand même
prince héritier d'arabie saoudite est
soupçonné puis sérieuse payer quoi que
ce soit les des preuves vidéo d'avoir
commandé un assassinat et mais
le cachemire
la politique nationale de la
grande-bretagne ainsi très con
fournisseur d'armes à l'arabie séoudite
et donc c'est compliqué et la politique
autour des événements comme ça donc
c'est sûr que l'arabie saoudite est une
tradition islamiste très très forte il
n'aurait pas pu assister à une cérémonie
chrétienne parce que les chrétiens ne
sont pas autorisés en arabie saoudite
mais c'est sûr aussi que dans un
événement comme ça des conversations de
couloir à sienne place qui ne t'a pas
peut-être la place ailleurs c'est
important aussi dans participé pendant
de conversations de couloirs les princes
arabes des princes des émirats n'était
pas content d'être dans l'autobus était
même pour fontan de deux allèles qu'on
engage dans l'abbaye de pas leur donner
une place prééminente ces gens là sont
habitués dans la hiérarchie a occupé le
sommet il ne se voyait pas traité comme
d'autres princes et hills a donné lieu à
des discussions très très ferme ça et
non ils salissent salir but a totalement
on a fait mais vous savez pour
l'empereur du japon qui sort rarement de
son pays
sa femme qui tarde dépression qui n'est
pas sortie depuis très très longtemps
ils sont sortis du japon pour l assister
aux funérailles d'elizabeth et où ils
ont pris l'autobus très modestement il
était aux funérailles on les a vus
pourtant ils ont un statut encore plus
élevé
et temporaires
alors il faut aller tout de suite
rejoindre catherine gauthier qui a
assisté donc à cette cérémonie à
l'abbaye de westminster catherine une
cérémonie très solennelle très
traditionnelle et fastueuse
grandiose effectivement céline et on a
senti les proches de la reine elizabeth
2 ému mais en retenu en vraiment déjà
dans la procession au début de cette
cérémonie à laquelle ont participé deux
de ses arrière petits enfants
on sentait vraiment que c'était un
moment important un moment solennel mais
qu'on allait pas nécessairement laissé
entrevoir toutes les émotions peut-être
que ça sera plus tard parce que ras
cérémonie privée et ce soir au château
de windsor avec les proches de la reine
elizabeth ii alors vous savez la reine
avait écrite ses voeux pour certaines
choses en tout cas dans cette cérémonie
la céline entre autres pour cette
cornemuse qu'on a entendues et qui était
très symbolique vers la fin de la
cérémonie
on l'a vu jouer le joueur de cornemuse
et tout à coup il s'est retourné et il a
quitté l'enceinte et le sont aussi c'est
était graduellement un peu comme si
c'était la métaphore du départ du départ
de l'arenh finalement alors tout cela
était bien sûr devant les yeux de 2010
ni terre les gosses qui a lui aussi
ne lectures religieuses et à
l'archevêque de canterbury qui a lui
voulu parler de son dévouement du
dévouement la dédier vraiment sa vie à
son rôle de reine je pense qu'on peut
entendre d'ailleurs un extrait
les deux
aston
martin ou
de
flynn a
indiqué l'ong forum
chioui story font
montre de
wipro est
maintenant catherine la reine entame son
dernier voyage vers windsor où elle sera
inhumée aux côtés de
de son époux le prince philip
et je vous parlais du silence tout à
l'heure céline on a aujourd'hui encore
interdite ou le transport aérien au
dessus de londres même au dessus de
weeds ans pour ce transport à la fin de
la journée et des centaines de vols qui
ont été annulés si bien que le silence
ils seront là jusqu'à la toute fin de ce
cortège je vous disais ce soir en
arrivant ouenza y aura cérémonie et
ensuite une cérémonie pour les proches
de la reine elizabeth ii qui vont
pouvoir se recueillir et ensuite elle
sera conduite à son dernier repos en la
chapelle saint georges bien sûr dans la
crypte royale au près comme vous disiez
de son mari le principe auprès de son
mari de son père également george vi et
de la reine mère et les cendres aussi de
sa de sa soeur margrethe un son dans ce
château de windsor merci beaucoup
catherine
vous en prie
[Musique]
les grands
si la can
sol à l'arc de wanted
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
non
[Musique]
ah ah
[Rires]
[Musique]
ah ah
à
alors voilà le cortège est arrivé donc à
l'arc de wellington on attend maintenant
qu'il soit placé dans un corbillard qui
l'amènera ensuite
le
35 km de l'est de la capitale
[Musique]
où la reine sera
un peu plus tard dans la stricte
intimité
en soirée elle reposera aux côtés de son
époux le prince philip de son père le
roi george ii 6 de sa mère ainsi que de
sa soeur la princesse margaret avant
cela il y aura une autre cérémonie
devant plusieurs centaines d'invités
donc un petit peu plus intime et
cérémonie qui sera dirigé par le doyen
de l'unsor si ce n'est qu'après cette
cérémonie que le corps de la reine sera
descendu à ce moment là dans la crypte
royale
donc c'est aussi la dernière étape à dos
de ce long périple à londres en fait
large de wellington et qu'il faut dire
c'était construit pour célébrer les
victoires contre napoléon est à
l'origine ils étaient plusieurs mètres
plus loin il eu des protestations
trouvais ça trop gros d'autant plus
qu'on voulait placer une énorme statue
de wellington là-dedans statue équestre
d'ailleurs on a déplacé le monument de
manière à ce qu'ils ouvrent sur une
grande avenue hainaut on a placé non pas
une statue de wellington mais au kadrige
c'est à dire quatre chevaux cm au dessus
du monument et c'était un des points de
repère de londres là c'est vraiment
l'entrée de hyde park et liu grain grand
symbole aussi parce qu'on célèbre les on
commémore les victoires contre napoléon
s'est dit trouver plusieurs endroits
jadis la gare simple et wellington
plusieurs endroits sont faites pour
célébrer ce ce grand général finalement
qui ont emporté les toits et il son
corps et même à l'abbaye de westminster
est une des personnalités qui se trouve
la gr g jalon dans l'histoire de
l'angleterre
encore là un moment très solennel très
protocolaire aussi où on va transporter
donc sur corps bien on va transporter
donc le cercueil dans ce corps bien pour
se diriger vers windsor et ce sont les
régime de la garde à pied de la maison
du roy qui eux
des représentants des 5 e régiment qui
va transporter le cercueil vers le
corbillard et pour compléter à propos de
de l'arche de wellington un des fils de
la reine victoria elle a nommé son fils
arthur
justement pour en 1 heures du duc de
wellington et
le prince arthur a été à duke de
connaught qui a été gouverneur général
du canada dans les années 1800
donc with other un des endroits préférés
de la reine oui elle passait ses
week-ends c'était là canales détonne
c'était vraiment là chez elle si on peut
dire buckingham ça va présenter le
protocole pendant la semaine et la
résidence édition la résidence
officielle
je pense que en général elles mais pas
trop mais enfin parce que ces séquences
et beaucoup de courant d'eramet
mais windsor c'était vraiment chez elle
est donc un endroit où il ya aussi une
très belle chapelle qui et qui fait
partie des chapelle royale qui
l'allemand qui est non seulement sa
chapelle mais aussi la chapelle de
l'ordre de la jarretière donc on verra
quand on entre dans cette chapelle
toutes les railleries qui est tout
autour les drapeaux qui représente les
bannières de nombreuses de l'ordre de la
jarretière et c'est très surprenant dans
un certain sens parce que c'est très
très différents
enfin pour ce départ en métal
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
c'est la fin de l'hommage à la reine
pour la partie londres maintenant le
corbillard se dirige vers windsor une
quarantaine de kilomètres il devrait
arriver vers autour de 10 heures et il y
aura une autre cérémonie avant bien sûr
que la reine soit inhumée dans la
chapelle saint georges du château de
windsor je retrouve maintenant à
zeewolde gorgui ce qui est toujours
devant le palais de buckingham alors
quelle était l'ambiance lorsque le
cercueil est passé à z
céline c'est vraiment triste en fait
très silencieux les gens ont vu passer
le cortège et vous savez juste devant
les grilles du palais y avait tout tous
ces employés tous les gens qui l'ont
côtoyé tous les jours dans le conti
quotidien vous savez toutes ces
personnes qui travaillent dans l'ombre
qui travaillait au palais de buckingham
ils étaient tous alignés en rang et le
cortège est passé je dirais qu avec
beaucoup d'émotion dans la foule elle
était silencieuse y avait une espèce de
respect si vous voulez envers cette
cette reine qui les arts qui les a
gouverné contre 10 mais pendant pendant
70 ans et c'était assez très solennelle
et puis a eu tout à tous les tous les
membres de la famille royale derrière le
roi charles le prince le prince harry le
prince william et vous savez pour la
foule s'ils ont l'impression de les
connaître personnellement parce que ça
fait presque 70 ans que les britanniques
suit la vie de cette famille on connaît
on a connu les divorces les décès aussi
les décès de la mère diana et là c'est
la reine qui décèdent donc les gens
étaient les gens réalisent en fait
qu'elle ne sera plus là et vous savez
pour beaucoup de britanniques et saas et
revenus extrêmement souvent c'est un peu
leur boussole morale c'était un peu un
repère moral quand les politiciens les
déçoivent quand il ya des scandales
politiques on a eu énormément en grande
bretagne récemment avec cow boys johnson
la famille royale et surtout la reine
était toujours la droite et ça les
rassure et là de voir qu'elle ne sera
plus là beaucoup d'entre nous disait on
a un peu perdu on sait pas ce que
l'avenir nous réserve on n'est pas
habitué parce qu'il nya qu elle qu'on a
connus donc un peu un sentiment
d'insécurité et écouter une dame
justement qu'on a qu'on a rencontré tout
à l'heure ils ont fait tout londres en
fait a fait le deux minutes de silence
assez c'est assez incroyable même
appliquer des risques est normalement un
endroit où il ya énormément en de gens
il y avait aucune publicité tout était
en noir et puis quand il ya eu des deux
minutes de silence tout le monde c'est
vraiment arrêter et respectueusement ce
silence à écoutons justement cette femme
à propos de la reine
christine
[Musique]
on sent une certaine inquiétude quand
même sur ce qui arrivera par la suite et
puis la réalité qui va les rattraper à
partir de demain puisque depuis
plusieurs jours tout était un peu
suspendue est arrêté pour cet hommage à
la reine je vois aussi sur les images
les gens qui lancent des leurs bouquets
de fleurs au passage du cortège delà de
la reine quand le cercueil passe les
gens jettent leur eau leur bouquet de
fleurs en hommage à la reine est donc
dans les prochaines heures à z c'est au
château de windsor que tout ça va se
déplacer se terminer aussi
tout à fait s'il insitec assez
incroyable c'est qu'en fait elle avait
un pouvoir symbolique mais quand même
elle à elle a touché le coeur des
britanniques malgré tout donc elle
terminera son parcours ou au château de
windsor un château cas l'affectionné
parce que c'est là qu'elle a passé
beaucoup de temps durant la seconde
guerre mondiale vous savez les enfants
de l'andrh été évacuées dont qu'elle
était beaucoup château de windsor un
château qui avait brûlé en
1992 donc beaucoup de commentateurs ici
lisez comment elle allait retrouver sa
mère la reine mère qui est enterré là
dans le vol 3 yal son père le roi george
george 6 également son mari le prince
philip bien commentateurs disaient que
son père va la retrouver qui va lui dire
tu es bien fait ça on est fiers de toi
c'était une famille aussi qu'ils étaient
très proches on se souvient on se
souvient tous ces photos qu'on voyait de
la reine avec ses parents quand elle
était plus jeune avec sa soeur margaret
c'est une famille qui était très unie
donc elle va retrouver donc cette
famille et surtout son époux le prince
philip parce que on se souvient que
ç'avait été un départ
une perte très difficile pour la révéler
elle avait été très fatigué après c'est
les funérailles de son mari très bien
merci beaucoup à z tout à fait à l'aise
en prêt à les y avait
lancé ça c'est surtout que c'était en
tant de co vide donc on se souvient de
la reine tout seul au château de windsor
justement à la chapelle saint georges
habillés en noir où elle était en deuil
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas autant de la
cause ils pouvaient pas se réunir
pouvait pas avoir tous les membres de la
famille autour d'elle et les
britanniques se souviendront toujours de
cette image là où une seule elle pleure
un peu son mari et le scandale à cette
époque là c'est que volition ne se
faisait peser défaite à downing street
donc ça ça aussi scandalisé les anglais
d'un côté mais jusqu'à jusqu'au bout
même quand elle a perdu son mari elle
est restée très droite elle a respecté
les règles du gouvernement et c'est tout
ça que les britanniques reconnaissent
cette gratitude qu'ils ont envers elle
si vous voulez oui très bien merci à z
et donc en devenant roi charles iii
devient également le chef du
commonwealth on en parlait tout à
l'heure marc isabelle si une
organisation qui vise en fait à
maintenir des liens politiques
économiques culturels entre plusieurs
ancienne colonie britannique est une
organisation à laquelle tenait beaucoup
la reine elizabeth oui tout à fait et
c'est une organisation donc la forme
moderne du commonwealth qui a vu le jour
en 1949 à l'époque il n'y avait que neuf
membres aujourd'hui on en compte 56
alors les pays membres peuvent y adhérer
volontairement
est une organisation qui est non
contraignante mais parmi les 56 états en
a 15 qui dont le roi charles iii et le
chef d'état mais le togo et le gabon ce
sont les deux derniers pays à avoir
rejoint de common word cette année en
2022 et ici vous voyez la carte donc des
15 pays dont le roi charles ii iii et le
chef d'état est quoi sert donc le common
word bien ce test une organisation dont
qui sert à rassembler les membres qui
ont des liens économiques politiques
culturels et les pays membres se
rassemblent une fois chaque deux ans
pour se rencontrer sa offre une tribune
diplomatique notamment pour les pays
plus petits donc d'avoir des échanges
avec les grandes puissances et la
dernière rencontre elle s'est déroulée
en juin 2022 au rwanda et c'est charles
iii qui était présent donc pour siéger à
la tête de l'organisation et vous savez
avec la mort d'elizabeth 2 mais certains
se questionnent si les liens vont se
rendre pour certains états du
commonwealth
on pense notamment à la barbade parce
qu'en novembre 2021 à la barbade rompu
ses liens avec la monarchie britannique
et on sait que dans les antilles un
mouvement d'indépendance certains pays a
qui veulent rompre leurs liens avec la
monarchie on pense notamment à la
jamaïque au belize aussi qui ont
récemment dit qu'il souhaitait donc
rompent leurs liens avec la monarchie
oui beaucoup de questions et
d'incertitudes à ce sujet là on va tous
eu d'ailleurs allé du côté de la
nouvelle zélande indépendante du royaume
uni depuis dès décennies mais où tout
comme oncle qu'au canada le souverain
britannique demeure le chef d'état j'en
parle avec richard tadié que l'on
retrouve à wellington il est passé
minuit chez vous mais j'imagine que
beaucoup de gens ont dû regarder cette
cette cérémonie aujourd'hui quelles ont
été les réactions à ses funérailles et
au décès de la reine
bonsoir bonjour à vous bonsoir ici
évidemment on est un peu très tôt le
matin alors oui c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
une certaine émotion ici ensuite au à la
disparition de la reine elizabeth car
elle était aussi la reine de la
nouvelle-zélande est tout simplement
très tôt le matin le jour de son décès
la première ministre cdh à avermes avait
convoqué les médias au parlement pour
présenter ses condoléances avait confié
quelques anecdotes concernant sa
relation avec la reine elizabeth elle a
conclu en la qualifiant comme quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire durant les heures qui
ont suivi cette annonce plusieurs
personnes se sont ensuite rassemblées
sur le front de mer si à wellington pour
voir là mais l'armée de terre tirer 96
coup de canon 96 comme l'âge de la reine
elizabeth
l'armée de terre qui a également fait
ensuite le fameux haka la danse
traditionnelle maorie 1 vous connaissez
certainement en hommage à la reine les
jours qui ont suivi les plusieurs
plusieurs dizaines pardon de personnes
ont continué à déposer des fleurs au
pied du parlement et à l'ambassade du
royaume uni à wellington lio plus il ya
eu aussi plusieurs livres de
condoléances placé dans les bâtiments
publics ainsi qu'au parlement pour
permettre aux néo zélandais d'exprimer
leurs condoléances ou même leurs
souvenirs liés à la reine elizabeth et
puis des drapeaux sur les maisons
étaient encore aussi en berne
aujourd'hui pour ce dixième et dernier
jour de deuil national mais pour ce qui
est des funérailles la plupart des néo
zélandais bien regardant ce moment même
chez eux devant leur télévision
puisqu'il est comme on disait presque
une heure du matin et que les cérémonies
ont commencé ici dès 22h
alors qu'on voit ici des photos de ce
qui se passe à windsor des préparatifs
qui attendent donc le cercueil de la
reine mais donc on se posait la question
est ce que en nouvelle zélande il ya une
réflexion sur l'avenir de la monarchie
avec maintenant c'est la disparition de
la reine l'arrivée du nouveau roi parce
que votre première ministre johanna
haden en avait un peu parlé elle avait
dit que ça se ferait probablement
qu'elle libère qu'on mettrait un terme à
la monarchie où il y est monarchique de
son vivant mais oui c'était les propos
qu'elle avait déjà eu d'ailleurs en 2010
huit ans la première ministre yacin
d'harardere nous l avait dit justement
que ce qu'elle ne verrait certainement
la fin de la monarchie en nouvelle
zélande de son vivant et pourquoi pas le
début d'une république propos d'ailleurs
qu'elle a renouvelé la semaine dernière
tout en assurant que cela ne devrait pas
arriver dans le coup tu es dans le court
terme et que toutefois la relation entre
la nouvelle zélande la monarchie
britannique allait s'approfondir avec le
nouveau roi charles iii en tout cas au
sein de la population ce n'est pas
vraiment un problème premièrement
puisque la nouvelle zélande se trouvent
déjà très loin géographiquement du
royaume uni mais aussi parce que la
monarchie ne coûte quasiment rien aux
contribuables aux contribuables néo
zélandais si ce n'est qu'un dollar par
an et par habitant un dollar symbolique
mais qui fait toutefois un total de 3
millions de dollars canadiens par an en
tout cas elle a dit qu'elle organisera
pas de référendum sur la question
maintenant qu'ils avaient d'autres
priorités mais comment réagissent les
maoris parce que bon vous en avez parlé
de ça leur met la couronne devait
protéger leurs droits leur territoire or
en un siècle ils ont perdu 90% de leurs
terres quoi ils ont subi toute une
assimilation
oui alors écouter leurs sentiments il
est là c'est sûr peut-être même pour
toujours d'ailleurs à ce propos il ya eu
plusieurs réactions qui seront suivis
de la reine ou parlement néo-zélandais
par exemple avec l'un des membres
représentant du parti maori ramery white
city l'a déclaré je cite que l' empire
britannique et par conséquence la
monarchie s'était construite sur des
terres et des ressources volées aux
peuples indigènes et malgré le deuil qui
devraient être respectées qui demeurait
très tôt respecter la reine ne pouvait
pas être séparé de l'institution qu'elle
représentait une déclaration qui
représente la grande majorité de ceux
qui pensent les maoris en nouvelle
zélande rappelons que la nouvelle
zélande sont annexés à la grande
bretagne en 1840 à la suite du traité de
waitangi prêtait qui étaient basés sur
un partage équitable des terres et des
ressources mais qui s'est finalement
achevée par une colonisation du complot
marie par les britanniques sandy vee des
guerres et des conflits qui durent
jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc pour résumer
oui les maoris aimerait aujourd'hui
sortir du commonwealth mais aussi et
sans doute jamais c'était avoir comme
est colonisée par les britanniques sans
doute mais pour l'instant pas de
changement en vue à court terme si je
comprends bien
non à court terme dans je pense que la
nouvelle zélande a davantage dialoguer
avec le roi charles ix et maintenir ses
relations d epuis ce d'autant plus y
aura certainement pas de référendum dont
ces gens ma vie quelque chose qui va se
passer un peu plus naturellement dans
les années à venir mais on parle à mon
avis de plusieurs décennies très bien
richard teint dié collaborateurs à
wellington en nouvelle zélande merci
beaucoup nous avons ouvert cette petite
fenêtre sur ce qui se passe chez vous
merci
merci toujours de bonne journée et parmi
ces pays du commonwealth le kenya
également un pays qui a toujours occupé
une place spéciale dans la ville dans la
légende de la reine puisque c'est là
souvenez-vous en 1952 qu'elisabeth avait
appris la mort de son père le roi george
6 elle devenait ainsi rennes à l'âge de
25 ans je jouais maintenant charlotte
simonard une de nos collaboratrices à
nairobi
bonsoir chez vous bon matin peut-être
chez vous il est prêt nous nous sommes
alors les funérailles de la reine
viennent de se terminer comment est-ce
qu'on réagit est ce qu'elles ont suscité
un grand intérêt au kenya
alors ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
les principales chaînes de télévision
kényanes ont effectivement en retransmis
en direct les funérailles de la reine
mais pour être honnête qui a été
particulièrement scrutés et commentée
ici ce sont les premiers pas du nouveau
président kényan william ruto qui est
arrivé en france il ya une semaine à
peine et qui faisait ses premiers pas
sur la scène c'est ça qui a été
particulièrement commenté depuis ce
matin les kényans ont un intérêt
évidemment pour ses funérailles elle
dirait en tant qu événement
international historique voilà il
regarde ça avec attention mais il
n'était pas l' ont scotché cet après
midi devant leur écran de télévision à
suivre cet événement de manière assidue
donc ils ont d'autres priorités mais
quand même quel est leur sentiment face
à la monarchie parce que la famille
royale rappelle aussi certains souvenirs
très douloureux là de toute cette
période coloniale
oui tout à fait alors ils ont deux prix
aux préoccupations aujourd'hui c'est sûr
mais il ya quand même cet attachement à
l'archi vous savez c'est vous disiez à
l'instant c'est ici que la reine a
appris à l'âge de 25 ans qu'elle
devenait à quel devenir reine à c'était
lors d'une tournée dans comment noël
avec le prince philip une tournée
effectuée au long son père qui était
malade à l'époque et durant leur séjour
au kenya ils se sont accordé une petite
escapade romantique en safari 2 en 4
heures à 150 km de nairobi où je me
trouve dans un hôtel perché en haut des
arbres la plus observée à la fin de
sauvages il ya le dira que c'était l'un
des moments les plus extraordinaires de
sa vie et c'est là que le lendemain
effectivement elle apprend la mort de
son père donc son accession au trône est
en fait cette histoire la princesse qui
monte un jour en haut d'un arbre qui
s'est réveillés au petit matin reine
d'angleterre est encore retransmise ici
au kenya non sans une certaine fierté
c'est ça qui fait que le kenya a tous
une place assez importante dans son
coeur et ça continue avec les jumelles
les nouvelles générations puisque le
kenya elle fait partie des destinations
privilégiées des membres de la famille
royale britannique infondées vous c'est
ici que william a demandé la main de
kate middleton en 2010 dans une réserve
du kenya donc ces souvenirs quand on
parle de deux peut-être de réaction un
peu plus mitigé les souvenirs de la
période qu'elle coloniale qu'est ce que
on le sent aussi on s'en serait certain
ressentiment chez vous quand même
oh oui tout à fait c'est c'est une
relation qui reste tout de même
ambivalence ya encore beaucoup de
souffrances liées à l'histoire de la
colonisation avance avec quelques jours
après la mort d'elizabeth un chroniqueur
bien connu du public kényans at 8 et à
personne ne mentionne que votre les
britanniques ont fait au kenya
lorsqu'elle est la bête est devenue
reine et c'est vrai que dans les années
50-60 dans les premières années de son
règne jusqu'en 1963 l'indépendance du
kenya et bien c'est là où l'oppression
britanniques contre les
anticolonialistes kényan a été
particulièrement sanglante et violentes
ont pas on pense à la tribu des manobo
ou à l'époque qui a lancé finalement ce
ce mouvement anti anti colons à l'époque
qui a été particulièrement aux prix mais
on parle de son 1000 morts côté kényan
durant ces années là et puis c'est une
affaire encore très actuel récemment il
ya quelques semaines à peine au mois
d'août deux tribu kényane de la région
de kericho est une région très connu
pour ses plantations de thé ajustements
et bien elles ont saisi la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme elles
ont attaqué la grande bretagne en
justice pour ses exactions commises dans
l'ex cinq ans 60 on parle des massacres
des viols et du vol de leurs terres dont
il réclame la propriété aujourd'hui
alors peut-être des discussions à venir
donc sur l'avenir
des liens avec le common word et avec la
monarchie au kenya charlotte simona
remercie beaucoup de tout c'est de tous
et du talent de toutes ces informations
nous avons rappelé aux 6,7 cette partie
de l'histoire d'elizabeth donc au kenya
quand même un endroit important pour l
merci beaucoup
c'est vrai
alors il nous reste quelques minutes
avant de nous quitter nous allons
prendre une petite pause de deux
familles royales et on va revenir juste
après donc vous voyez le cortège qui se
dirige toujours vers windsor où il
devrait arriver aux alentours de 10
heures donc on va continuer de suivre
toutes ces développements et les
funérailles de la reine elizabeth qui se
poursuivent donc on va se laisser sur
des images des cérémonies un peu plus
tôt aujourd'hui et on va se retrouver
vers 9h30 donc on se laisse notamment
pour un bulletin d'information à rdi et
on se retrouve pour la suite un peu plus
tard merci beaucoup
[Musique]